The Joe Rogan experience
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
Oh righty.
Uh,
you're looking at something.
What's going on too loud,
too loud.
Turned down.
Were very obnoxious here.
I like to be loud.
Is this it right here?
Check,
check,
check.
There we go.
Is that fine?
Do you want to fuck with it?
It's that button right there.
One right below the clock.
Here we go.
Welcome to my country,
my friend.
I know in your country it's frozen solid and you escaped.
Came down here.
Did a little drinking last night maybe.
Maybe.
Oh No.
Yeah.
Yes.
I've been drinking lots of water and that's what I was telling you that,
you know,
these long podcast was just wondering if I.
You can absolutely take a pee break.
Do not be intimidated by the long form.
We just try and have a conversation.
Are you working on your new book and your new book is entitled the Atheist
Muslim.
That's that title is.
That's like jumbo shrimp or military intelligence.
Is that a one of those?
It was a
partly a tongue and cheek thing and then there's a serious element to it,
to the tongue in cheek thing is I was,
I have a friend who's a,
she calls herself a feminist Muslim,
so I'm not going to name her right now.
Okay.
Um,
so I always have fun conversations with her,
you know,
she's sort of nominally religious,
right.
And uh,
you know,
uh,
that was like,
how can you be a feminist Muslim?
Isn't that like being a mediating vegetarian or you know,
it's a contradiction.
And she's like,
well no,
there's parts of it that I liked.
Parts of it I don't like.
So I just,
uh,
me choose essentially saying that she cherry picks.
So I figured.
And then you know,
there's other things,
like there's lgbt Muslims in Toronto,
there's a big community of great people.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Transgender,
Muslims,
transgender,
gay and lesbian,
Muslim.
That's a small crowd that's,
it's hard to find your peers and it's,
it's,
it's actually quite sizeable and it's like,
wait,
you mean that 10 people,
how many transgender Muslims are there?
Oh,
I don't,
I don't know what number,
but they practice like,
yeah,
they practice their religious,
they do,
um,
they do like Friday prayers and you know,
things like that have a lot of events that go on.
So,
but clearly in the Muslim religion like homosexuality and you know,
there's a lot of,
there's,
there's a lot of areas of that that are looked down upon.
Right,
right.
So how does one justify that or rationalize
in their head?
It's,
I think what's happening is the Muslim community that's in North America and
Canada,
the United States,
they're a little bit more progressive.
They're sort of going through what all of the other religious groups went
through when they came here as they kind of have like,
you know,
the religion part is really more of an identity issue.
They have broad beliefs like they'll believe in God,
they'll believe with the stick to some traditions.
But um,
you know,
the large part of it,
like they're integrating pretty well and it's very different in Europe.
It seems sort of
for like,
um,
American Jews perhaps like a lot of American Jews are not really religious at
all.
Like I have a lot of friends that will call themselves Jus,
like my friend Ari Shaffir,
clearly an atheist,
but yet if you talk to him,
he'll tell you he's a Jew.
Yeah.
And there's that.
That was kind of.
Yeah.
The idea of the title of the book is it's a job that the cherry picking thing.
I was thinking if you could cherry pick up,
you're going to be a feminist Muslim and lgbt Muslim if you.
I can cherry pick all.
I can cherry pick all the way to non belief.
Yeah.
I'll keep the things I like,
like,
uh,
like I love the Ramadan feasts.
I grew up with that.
Um,
you know,
the,
it's just very communal.
Families get together.
It's great.
The IED holidays are great.
I'm tax exempt status.
You know,
why not keep that.
But what can you only have tax exempt status if you operate a religion though,
right?
I mean,
I'm kidding about that.
You can have to operate your own church.
Yeah,
I probably won't be doing that anytime soon.
You can do it if you want to.
My friend Alex Grey does that.
Our friend Alex,
the painter,
he's this amazing psychedelic artist and he has this,
uh,
this organization called the chapel of the sacred mirrors and uh,
what he's essentially does is,
has done rather is create his own religion and he has tax exempt status.
Although his is,
I think that not like the state recognizes it,
but his town doesn't want to recognize that they want like local taxes.
And it's very interesting because people are cool with religions as long as
they're really old,
as long as they're,
like,
as soon as you know who made the religion,
whether it's even mormonism gets looked down upon because Joseph Smith,
although he lived in the 18 hundreds,
everybody,
there's a historical record of Joseph Smith.
It's pretty easy to track.
Yeah.
Whereas,
you know,
scientology is the most made fun of and that is by a science fiction writer in
the 19 fifties.
It's the easiest to track.
It's like,
it's right there.
Anything newer than that,
you're like,
come on,
get the fuck Outta here.
I know you wouldn't believe it.
And even though it's older religions,
if you brought them back,
if they started recently,
some of the,
it's just,
uh,
you know,
when religious people make fun of scientology and what isn't,
it's always entertaining because,
you know,
you're talking about like,
well yeah,
Angel was a real and virgin births really happened,
but like this fucking Mormon.
So it's uh,
I know it's,
it's Kinda funny when you look at it,
I think I saw this comic where there were these two religious groups fighting.
They're running against each other and swords and one of them was screaming,
two plus two equals five.
The other one was saying two plus two equals three.
And then we about to fight about it.
And that's really what it's like sometimes when you look at it.
Well,
did see the,
the anger
from the people that were upset at Neil Tyson,
Neil degrasse Tyson for tweeting about Isaac Newton,
Isaac Newton,
who was born on December 25th.
And you know,
there were,
there was a Darwin or Newton that was born in December,
25th Newton.
Was it Newton?
Yeah.
And he was,
he was tweeting about,
you know,
w w this great man being born on this great day and so many fucking religious
people got really angry at him.
Although he said nothing negative whatsoever about religion.
Yeah.
But they will,
uh,
you know,
you shouldn't on our holiday.
And it to me sort of highlights what religion is for a lot of people.
It's,
it's a group that you belong to.
It's a team.
Like I'm a patriots fan,
you know,
don't fuck with our team.
And it really does become something like that.
And when you're talking about American Jews or Muslims maybe perhaps that don't
really follow all of what's in the Koran,
they just decided to cherry pick.
It's kind of a similar thing you're dealing with.
It is a silhouette similar thing.
That's probably a good thing.
I mean,
that's how people sort of progress forwards,
right?
I,
uh,
I mean we're talking about Jews in the Old Testament is,
you know,
we're talking about killing gay people like leviticus 2013 says it,
it says,
you know,
if there's two men and you find them,
together and the way that a man should be with a woman,
then there'll be put to death.
That's exactly what it says.
But most Jews don't really take that seriously.
They have built beyond it.
Um,
even,
you know,
Christians,
one of the things I look at is Catholics.
The pope says you should not use birth control or you know,
abortion is a bad thing.
The majority of Catholics are there.
Pro Choice,
you know,
they have premarital sex.
Uh,
they are,
you know,
they're perfectly fine with all these things because the majority are pro choice
over here in the U.
S air.
Is it the zero,
like a statistic,
the prove that.
Yeah,
there is.
I don't know the exact number,
but the majority of Catholics in the United States are actually pro choice.
That's interesting because I would have not thought that was true.
Yeah,
I would have thought that it would probably be at the very least 50 slash 50,
but at the very more likely skewing towards prolife.
No,
it's,
it's definitely.
I mean there are pro choice and Joe Biden's a Catholic practicing Catholic and
he's also pro choice.
Big is also an idiot though
when we were a comics back in the funniest.
Yeah,
he is.
Yeah.
Well people forget about this,
about Joe Biden,
but you know,
not to.
Everybody makes mistakes and I'm sure it probably wasn't his fault,
but uh,
in the 19 eighties he was running for president and he plagiarized a huge chunk
of John f Kennedy's speeches.
Yeah,
he did.
And we used to do Joe Biden tonight at stitches and Joe Biden night would be
like,
we would all go up and try to remember each other's acts.
Like I would try to do my friends act and he would try to do my act.
We tried it,
we'd steal each other's jokes.
It was like an inside thing that we would do on open mic night.
Yeah.
That,
uh,
this guy,
I forget who came up with the idea,
but we would call it,
he was such a known plagiarist that we would call it Joe Biden tonight.
Yeah.
That kind of.
I think that was one of the major things that killed his campaign.
Not the only thing.
Yeah.
But now he's the vice president and it's sort of never brought up.
Yeah,
he's,
I think he's done.
There's a lot of stuff he's done that I think that kind of redeemed him,
you know,
I'm right.
But how did that not come up when he was debating Sarah Pailin?
It did.
And it didn't come up during the debate,
but during the campaign there were,
people will try to bring it up,
but I think that just,
it had been so long and he had done so much more since then,
like with foreign policy,
with the violence against women legislation and so on that people were willing
to let them get past.
And he has a really strong personal story too that he,
you know,
emphasized.
And so I think,
uh,
he was able to move past that.
It's interesting because a lot of times things like that are real career killers
and it was as far as like him being the actual president,
president,
like when people talk about Hillary running for president,
no one's talking about Joe Biden run for president.
If you noticed that like no one,
no.
Was he running for president?
He's not right,
but he's the vice president for eight fucking years and no one hates him.
You know,
it's not like he's Dan quayle where everybody's like,
get that fucking moron out of office.
He,
he never did.
Like even in the other campaigns,
whenever he's run,
he never really did too well.
I mean he was,
he was running against Obama to back into it and then Obama chosen was vice
president.
He,
I think he was always in the single digits.
Right.
But I mean he is the vice president.
He is.
I think that that would be like a prime candidate to keep the Democrats in a
position of power,
but now they're looking towards a woman instead.
Yeah.
Like Dude,
you're a liability.
It was like Dick Cheney,
right?
He was vice president,
but there's no fucking way he's going to.
He's probably the most hated vice president ever.
Dick Cheney,
like the most despised,
like there's some people that supported him for sure,
but the people that hated him really fucking hated it.
Yeah,
they did.
It was just such a money trail,
you know,
pointing him directly to Halliburton and all the,
the weapons of mass destruction fiasco and all that shit.
I just think he just seems really dodgy to me.
Like I always feel like there's something under the surface that's just really
explosive and evil.
Like he comes across that way.
Yeah.
He's definitely doesn't come across warm and compassionate and interesting.
It's hard to understand a guy like that.
Especially a guy that's gone through some serious health issues and he does.
It doesn't seem to have more heart attacks,
so we got a new heart.
He's a.
He had a heart transplant,
which is insane.
Yeah.
Before the heart transplant,
he had some sort of a device that eliminated his pulse.
He didn't have a pulse.
There was some artificial method of pumping blood through his body and if you
checked his pulse,
he didn't exist,
which is probably in the Bible somewhere,
you know,
a guy who was the death of millions.
I mean,
he's directly connected to the death of at least a million people and he doesn't
have a pulse.
Yeah,
that's,
that's dark shit.
Yeah.
That's a hell of a way to articulate it,
but yeah,
if it's accurate,
it's accurate.
I don't know how we got on this.
What we're talking about is people that are in groups.
I mean there's,
there's,
there's good things involved in being a group because it gives you some support
and it gives you some feeling of comradery and belong to a social structure.
But it's the.
The real issue though is groups against other groups diametrically opposed
groups like,
like right now being a Muslim is a very unpopular thing in a lot of parts of the
world.
The Charlie Hebdo thing,
this most recent isis video where they burned the Jordanian pilot ally.
That was just kind of shaking for hours.
I didn't watch it.
I didn't watch it either.
I've seen it all at this point.
I know what it looks like.
I've seen the beheadings and the assassinations and it's just like,
okay,
I get it.
There's evil people.
I get it,
but it's just like this.
It's almost like it's.
If you were a conspiratorially minded person,
if you're the type of person that believes black helicopters were circling your
house everyday,
taking scans of your phone and you.
I am,
you would say,
okay.
It's almost like we're creating this monster that so unbelievably horrific and
so impossible to to,
to feel any sympathy towards that.
It's like you,
you,
you want them all wiped off the face of the planet.
It's almost like they have become this so they're,
they're so evil in their acts are so horrendous that like,
it's the perfect instigating weapon like,
or the perfect perfect method of instigation that if you wanted to,
if you were like an evil dictator or the evil head of some sort of government
and you had this desire to go to war with another country,
like what you would create would be isis.
You would say,
alright,
we need some bullshit.
CIA propped up,
organization doesn't,
it's not real and we need them to be just so heinous.
So beyond belief that everyone agrees we should go over there and fuck them up.
Yeah.
I like,
I totally see the logic of that.
I don't obviously,
I don't think that's the case.
I don't think that's the case either,
but if it was going to be the case,
like isis is like the perfect candidate.
Yeah,
it's a prototype.
It's like that's exactly what you'd want.
Yeah.
It's like right in a Hollywood casting,
right?
Yeah.
And you know,
what's a,
like this whole idea that they're a fringe and you know,
that they don't have a lot of support.
You know,
it is one thing that yes,
they don't represent all Muslims,
like they don't even represent,
you know,
the majority of Muslims and everything.
But um,
unfortunately like I think they have a lot more support than we'd like to
believe.
Everybody who comes out and says that know there's just like a frame,
just a,
you know,
group of guys who are doing this stuff and nobody really follows them.
That's not true.
Like,
there's a lot of support and may you see it online,
you know,
I've talked to people online impact Stan who totally supportive isis.
Um,
it's a bizarre,
you know,
they are like,
they won't go out and commit those acts themselves,
but they will definitely share it on.
Well,
I'd follow some people online that are in Isis.
I follow their twitter accounts.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't follow them.
So like they know I'm falling on a farm,
so I bookmark their twitter page and I go back to it.
Yeah,
I'm sneaky like that.
But I mean,
I hate to say this,
but they do occasionally have good points.
And one of the good points was they,
after they beheaded one of these guys,
I forget which guy was,
I think it was a journalist that got beheaded over there.
It was one of the American guys.
They beheaded the,
this guy wrote one guy loses a body part and everyone goes crazy,
but thousands of people lose their entire lives and no one blinks an eye like
thousands.
I think the way you said it is thousands of people's bodies are blown to bits
and,
and no one blinks an eye.
Yeah,
that's a tough thing to argue against it.
That's what,
whenever this kind of thing happens,
you always have a,
you know,
the sort of Noam Chomsky or kind of,
um,
sort of mindset or you know,
what he thinks is that you've got us on this side and we're doing all these
terrible things and you've got them and they're doing these terrible things.
What's the difference?
I just,
I don't think it's as simple as that.
I mean,
I'm not saying that,
you know,
everything that the US is doing is great and defending all aspects of American
foreign policy.
But if you're going to have that balance,
you got to a sort of level the competition.
So,
you know,
the US has this,
the biggest,
strongest military in the world got loads of nuclear weapons.
So on,
like if isis had all of that,
how bad would they be and what would they do?
That's when you really sort of get an idea of the intentions and intentions
matter.
Right?
So you know,
they,
they do what they can and they go all out and they,
I think that,
you know,
like the [inaudible] that they killed,
right?
Or the Christians that they're killing in Mosul,
the poor people that the women in the gay people that throwing off buildings and
you know,
crucifying and stoning to death.
I mean,
these are not people who are oil hungry,
they're not people who have been sort of invading their lands or anything like
that.
These are,
these people have nothing to do with it.
They just have some of their crimes that they're just Shia.
They have a different belief in a different strain of Islam or their PA states,
you know,
they left Islam,
they changed their mind or they're,
you know,
they're a Christian,
they're non Muslims are infidels who are not going to subscribe to the,
you know,
the Isis philosophy.
They're not going to pay that tax,
that Jessia that they want them to pay.
So like,
you know,
I think that the foreign policy thing is an excuse specifically for people like
Isis.
It is like,
it helps them recruit people for sure.
Um,
it doesn't hurt,
but,
uh,
I don't think that that's the primary motive.
What do you think the primary motive is?
I think there's a lot of primary motives.
I think,
you know,
like the US foreign policy is one thing too,
but this is actually part of their religious belief.
You've had Sam Harris here,
he's talked about this as well as the beliefs and behavior and most of the time
when they're in here,
when you have an entire world and you're seeing these guys in there,
you know,
accurately quoting the Koran.
I mean,
there's a couple of verses in the Koran say behead disbelievers,
you know,
eight,
12,
you know,
you can google that,
like Sera eight verse 12 and 13,
47.
Four is another one says,
you know,
bighead disbelievers.
So they actually quote this stuff and they say Allahu Akbar when they do it and
they called themselves the Islamic state.
So,
and,
and they don't just target,
you know,
I'm sort of,
people were involved in US foreign policy or anything like that.
They actually target a poor people,
you know,
use minority groups.
She is,
you know,
gay people who are in Iraq and Syria,
that's what they do and this doesn't believe it.
So it's a lot more complicated.
I think that it is part of their religious belief.
And one thing you need to see when you go to their twitter accounts is that they
genuinely believe what they're doing is right.
It's okay when you are supported by the religion that you've sworn allegiance to
and sworn your life too when you're supported by the text.
Yeah,
it,
it really.
I mean,
that's sometimes all you need to justify horrendous,
horrible acts.
You just need to know that you're doing it in the name of God.
Well,
that's the text.
Is the religion in this case,
like the one thing that's universal,
you know,
people say Muslims are not a monolith and they're not.
I mean,
there's one point 6 billion Muslims in the world,
so they're obviously not all the same.
The ones in Indonesia,
Turkey,
Saudi Arabia,
they're all very different from each other.
Um,
but the one thing they all have in common is the Koran and belief in the Prophet
Muhammad.
So,
uh,
that the Quran again do,
you know,
has different interpretations,
but it's supposed to be an immutable texts and unlike a lot of Christians and
Jews who don't believe that,
they're like,
you know,
like with Christianity,
if you say that the Bible is a literal word of God,
you're part of,
I think 30 percent of the US population,
I think it is 30 percent that is considered fundamentalists where they believe
that it's a literal word of God in Islam,
Muslims among the vast majority of Muslims.
That is a fundamental requirement to believe that it is the literal word of God.
Like the,
the idea of scriptural inerrancy,
that anything that's in Chron that kept it can't be wrong.
So you'll have the more progressive people who try to justify it.
They'll never say,
well,
you know,
that verse in the Koran,
I don't believe in it.
I don't think it's right.
They'll try to justify it by saying at that time it was okay,
or it's being mistranslated or the word kill actually means embrace whatever it
is.
They look at the,
uh,
Arabic root.
So the,
um,
uh,
you know,
find other justifications for it,
but unfortunately to the rest of us who can read it and now you can google it in
all kinds of different translations and interpretations and commentaries and
you'd just find it online and when you see the words,
the words are what they are.
I want to be real clear here that I'm not justifying what they're doing or not
trying to exonerate them from the nature of what their crimes are.
But um,
what,
uh,
what I'm,
what I was going to get to was that,
is that dissimilar,
this belief that you can kill people because of the Koran because they're not
following the word of the cross.
Is that dissimilar than this belief that you can launch drones into these
nonspecific areas where,
you know,
this idea of surgical targets is pretty preposterous at this point.
When you look at the number of people,
the overwhelming number of people that are innocent that are killed by drones
versus the number of people that are guilty.
If you,
if you look at that and you look at this being sanctioned by the United States
government,
the constitution,
our ideas about law and justice and war,
those are also just things that are written down on paper.
I mean,
they might be less ideologically based and more,
more state based or more based on the idea of protecting our nation as opposed
to doing the will of God.
But it is one nation under God.
Ultimately,
this is,
you know,
this is what we say when we pledge allegiance now since the 19 fifties,
since they were worried about the big communist scare,
you know,
it used to be one nation indivisible with liberty and justice for all right?
Yeah.
Now it's one nation under God.
Um,
that was all because of communism.
That's,
that's when they didn't.
And most folks don't even realize I wasn't even in there until the 1950.
I was a reaction to like the,
uh,
the red scare.
Um,
but this,
this is the justification,
the horrific acts that are committed in,
in war,
nonspecific targets.
I mean,
when I say nonspecific,
obviously they're trying to get someone that's in a place,
but you know,
when you're shooting a fucking missile where,
you know,
a guy's cell phone is,
that's fairly nonspecific.
I mean,
yeah,
relatively speaking,
relatively spirit will look,
I think,
what are the numbers?
I think the numbers of versus like the amount of casualties that are civilians,
the actual people
that are to kill with drones.
It's something sane number.
It's like more than 80 percent civilians.
Here's,
so the drone thing is a little,
uh,
it's also a complicated issue.
There's this,
uh,
this writer,
her name is Farhan Dodge.
I mean she lives in Norway now,
but she's from that area.
She's from North Missouri stand where a lot of the drones were and she wrote
this article a couple of years ago,
I think it was in the daily times than Asian paper.
And then what she talked about was a sort of the different groups that are in
that area and like northwestern Pakistan,
the Pak Afghan border.
And she said that the locals over there a lot of times,
uh,
you know,
they feel like they're caught between the Taliban that's sort of taken over the
whole area and they,
you know,
they go out and they put a,
they're shooting young girls in the head for going to school and they're,
you know,
doing all this other bullshit.
And then on the other hand there is the Pakistani military and they're coming in
with their planes and they're trying to bomb and that's even more nonspecific.
So they feel a lot of them are actually in favor of it.
Like there's many of them.
That's what she said.
So I don't know how true that is.
Right.
But I mean,
it's definitely a plausible claim.
And so,
you know,
it's kind of anecdotal doing,
one person saying a lot of them are in favor of it.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
what happened was after she said this,
uh,
there were a lot of other accounts that came out that said the same kind of
thing.
I mean,
they,
they weren't saying that everybody's in favor of it.
They're saying that it's not as clear cut as people think it is.
So like with drones,
you know,
for instance,
if you like the idea is that when you.
I'm like,
you know,
these are decisions that are,
you got to choose between bad and worse,
like complicated decisions are never clear cut,
good or bad.
Right.
So I don't like the drone strikes.
I think it sucks that sometimes they're necessary,
but unfortunately I think sometimes they aren't necessarily like these are
people who are,
if you have a sniper it was going around killing hundreds of people and you want
to stop them and you know,
he's around a place and you have a choice between,
you know,
targeting this guy and taking him out and that may kill a few civilians.
Whereas if you don't do that,
it'll go out and you know,
he'll kill hundreds more people then and you,
you're making that call.
That's a really tough call to make.
I don't know if I could do it,
you know,
and,
but I,
I,
when you're running countries and we know when you have a foreign policy,
when you,
when you have to do something about something that's happening,
then it's a call that you have to make and it's a choice between bad and worse.
It seems so intensely archaic,
doesn't it?
Yeah.
Wasn't one of the articles that I pulled up was talking about an attempt to kill
41 men result in the deaths of an estimated 1000,
147 people.
So the drones in their attempt to kill 41 different people have killed more than
1000,
147 people.
That's just so.
Well for her.
She talked about this too.
So she talked about the uh,
like so in that area,
nobody's allowed there.
Okay.
So you're not like journalists don't go there because it's too dangerous.
Even.
What areas is that?
This is in northern south was stan.
Yeah,
in Pakistan.
Now the armies in there because they're fighting against them.
Recently after the Taliban has been like really focusing all their attacks in
within Pakistan,
they have attacked the army school,
um,
and killed all those kids and so on.
So now they're in there.
But before when a lot of these figures were coming out,
uh,
she said that,
that,
uh,
there's no UN people,
there's no independent sort of,
um,
uh,
you know,
watchdogs or agencies that are looking at it.
No journalist can go in there,
no politicians can go in there.
Even the police,
the police are scared to go in there because it's just completely ruled by the
Taliban and all these sort of militant elements.
So a lot of these numbers,
like if you look at the,
I think it was a report,
detailed report from Stanford and um,
they talked about how these numbers were arrived at and there's a wide range.
There's some people report their very low,
other people report their very high.
And that's not to say there haven't been civilian casualties.
There have been,
and that's terrible.
But um,
I think that during Bush's time when he just carried out a few drone strikes,
they were relatively nonsurgical.
I think Obama,
one of the reason that he decided to go ahead and continue the drone strikes is
that he founded the most surgical in the most accurate compared to all of the
other options that they had.
That's pretty scary when you think about.
Well,
it makes sense,
bad choosing bad and worse.
Right?
But it makes sense when you look at the numbers of innocence that have been
killed in the Iraq war.
Yeah.
Like mean mean it's arguable that it's close to a million dollars,
a million humans rather than.
I mean that's,
that's an insane amount of innocent people that had been killed by feet on the
ground,
missiles,
bombing campaigns,
all of the above.
And when you compare that to drone strikes,
that's the only way,
kind of like what they're saying.
Like it's more surgical than that way.
Then,
you know,
sending a bunch of tanks and a bunch of troops into a,
an area that is less surgical.
So like what the fuck is war man?
Yeah.
That's eventually come down to this that,
you know,
wore socks and you know,
we're going to have that debate.
I will agree with you.
It's terrible when you can avoid it,
you can,
but if you're of the view that sometimes it is necessary to prevent even larger
atrocities and you know,
sometimes you need to do it to stop it,
I think,
which is the view that I have.
I think that,
um,
if you,
the more surgical your methodology is and it seems like drone strikes tend to be
better,
a better option than the other ones.
I mean,
there's elements of it that I know about the debate,
like the fact that you're sitting far away,
it's very sort of inhuman don't contact.
You're very detached because,
you know,
you just,
it's like a remote control on.
They're firing off a missile.
Like that part of it sucks.
Uh,
but there's a lot of things about it that suck,
but I just don't know,
you know,
how else I don't know what other options there are to handle the situation and
it is affecting them.
Like,
it's not like the Taliban seemed to be more upset about the drone strikes and
anybody else,
you know,
that means that it is kind of hitting them and they,
they do know that the world has a lot of sympathy for civilian casualties.
They know that at that itself.
Just the fact that you know,
they,
they know that they can use these civilian casualties to their benefit that
automatically shows you that there is a,
there's an ethical difference between both sides.
So it's not.
Well,
you're saying that meaning that they do it on purpose,
that they have areas set up in high civilian population areas knowing that
they'll get hit in those areas and it will cause civilian deaths so that those
civilian deaths will be used to sort of promote their columns.
Yeah.
They,
I mean they absolutely do that.
I mean,
think about it again,
you were talking about getting in the mind of a conspiracy theorist and think
about if you were one of those people and you knew that a lot of people don't
agree with you.
Everybody thinks that,
you know,
you're back in the stone ages and so on,
but the one time you get a lot of sympathy is when there are a lot of innocence
killed.
And then you know,
everyone,
all of these powerful political figures and journalists,
everything around the world suddenly start,
um,
you know,
sort of coming to your site against your enemy.
Then why wouldn't you exploit that when you have nothing.
You have like shitty weapons,
you know,
you're living in the middle of nowhere.
And if that's the only power you have,
that's one of your strongest weapons,
you know,
you'd exploited everybody would,
I can certainly see that.
But I can also certainly see the argument that one of the best recruiting
methods for the Taliban or Al Qaeda is having your family blown up by a drone.
You know,
and that has happened to it.
And it works.
And that's what I'm saying.
This is really complicated.
It's,
it's,
are we in a state of perpetual war?
Um,
I don't know.
That's a,
I'm not qualified to answer.
What's this a weird war in that sense,
because all the wars throughout history seemed to have been about someone trying
to take over something,
whereas this one seems to be at least a big part of the root of it seems to be
religious ideology.
It is,
yeah.
It takes you back to that.
The Samuel Huntington paper,
the clash of civilizations.
What does that paper it's um,
he predicted it.
He was this a political scientist,
I think in the nineties.
He wrote this paper and later expanded into a book and it's called the clash of
civilizations.
It was like a sort of a prophecy about the future and um,
what kind of conflicts people going to get into.
And he said that it wouldn't be ideological.
This is about post Cold War and inside it won't be an ideological,
it'll be cultural and uh,
it'll be between like religious groups.
And he actually talked about the Islamic world and about seven or eight other
civilizations and how they're going to get into cultural conflict.
And,
and he was conservative and a lot of people criticized that and yeah,
that time I thought it was kind of,
you know,
it wasn't completely completely in line with it,
but now more,
you know,
as time goes on,
every once in a while go back to no to revisit the paper and it seems to make
more sense.
Almost like,
you know,
he kind of knew what he was talking about.
Have you ever tried to look objectively,
like if you were the engineer of modern society or modern civilization and he
tried to look objectively,
like sit on it in a high chair with a desk above the earth and garden,
how do I fix this mess?
How do I stop all these silly monkeys from blowing each other up and shooting
rockets from robots that fly above their cities and blowing up bombs and their
buildings?
How do you stop that?
Have you ever.
Have you ever tried to see like is there a way,
like a longterm short term,
any term way to sort of engineer this away?
I think the longterm.
I think we discount the role of a ideology and belief when it comes to this and
I don't know how to solve it,
but I know one way to move closer to solving it and that's just being honest
about what the problem is.
You know,
a lot of the problem,
like for example,
the Islamic state,
you know,
they're yelling,
Allahu akbar into the quoting the Koran and everything.
I this is it weak,
but you know,
cartoons,
people making cartoons and then getting shot up for it.
Like,
you know,
these are all things that,
there,
there is an identifiable issue.
There's a root cause here that everybody seems to deny it.
Like including all the prime ministers like this has nothing to do with
religion,
but just,
you know,
like I grew up in a Libya,
Saudi Arabia,
Pakistan.
I didn't come to North America until I was 24.
I grew up in pretty much Muslim majority countries and some very conservative
ones all the time.
And,
you know,
I just,
whenever I hear people say that this has nothing to do with religion,
it just doesn't make any sense to me.
Is that like an American liberal convenient thing to say because it makes you
look super sensitive and very noam Chomsky ask.
Yeah,
it does.
And then,
you know,
there's a,
a,
I don't know what goes into it.
I know that there's a lot of fear and going to people don't want to criticize
this.
Um,
you know,
we saw what happened with someone rusty,
all the way up to the Paris attacks.
So there is a fear of that and there's also a fear of being seen as a bigot.
That was,
I call it Islamophobia Phobia.
People like the word and you know,
I'm a phobia phobia.
I love it.
It's something that a lot of people relate to immediately.
Turn it,
here it is.
I hate that term.
Islamophobia.
And look,
what about Christian have phobia.
What's
hilarious to me is that a lot of quote unquote progressive,
very left wing people will openly mock Christianity while defending Islam or by
labeling people Islamophobic who are conservative.
Yeah,
that,
I mean you gotta you gotta stay consistent.
If you're a true liberal,
and I know everybody's saying this,
well unfortunately not everybody's saying it,
I wish more people were saying it,
but you know,
if you are,
for instance opposed to killing gay people,
you should be opposed to killing gay people,
whether it's in the KKK manifesto or the Bible or the Koran or in the Republican
Party,
you know,
or in Uganda,
it doesn't matter what it is,
if you're opposed to something you should be opposed to it across the board.
It doesn't suddenly become respectful that,
okay,
now,
well it's in the Bible.
So we got to respect that.
And respect for ideas is just such an overrated.
It's considered a virtue in respecting people's ideas and beliefs and ideas are
not people.
You know,
that kids and I was trying to,
that's the problem with the word Islamophobia,
is that it implies criticism of an idea and there is genuine anti Muslim
bigotry.
People do commit hate crimes against Muslims,
but um,
Muslims are people.
They are not,
I mean they're entitled to respect.
They have rights.
Islam itself is not a person,
it's just a,
it's a book,
it's an ideology,
it's an ideology is a bunch of ideas in a book so it doesn't have rights and
it's not entitled to respect.
So,
um,
so the idea of Islamophobia is a phobia of ideas that are irrational and
ancient.
Yeah.
That seems to be pretty smart,
but it's connected somehow or another to racism.
And this is where it gets weird because progressive people don't want to
criticize anybody with extra melanin.
Yeah.
Anybody that's remotely browner than them gets immediate free pass.
But see,
like the Boston bombers.
Right?
And there were from Dagestan?
Yeah.
They're from where they're from.
Caucasian.
Is that how you pronounce it?
Cocky,
but he doesn't do this or he's wrong.
He knows what beyonce is.
Wait is her ring sizes and shoe size.
He knows when she was born.
He knows who choose to date.
We need to talk later.
That's great.
Actually,
Boston bombers are actually from a place where the word Caucasian comes from the
caucus mountains.
So there from there.
So you know,
they were white that the underwear bomber was black.
The Jose Padilla was a Hispanic,
you know this,
so it's not a race.
All of these people were Muslim.
And the thing is,
if you're,
if you're saying that criticizing Islam is somehow racist,
you're assuming that all of Islam is a race.
What does that make you write that itself?
I mean,
that's,
that's exactly what racism is.
When you assume that everything that entire religion is one race.
Yes.
We're completely ignorant.
Yeah.
So there's some white,
blue eyed Muslims,
you know,
so yeah,
there's lots of,
if you look at Mecca,
you see like the people that are in Mecca,
you'll see redheaded people,
red haired people that are walking around with the traditional garb on,
circling back.
Yeah.
And then there's a Turkey.
So Turkey is a big Muslim country.
Egypt,
a big Muslim country.
Indonesia is Iran where everybody's Persian.
That there's the Arab world in the south.
Asians.
I mean there's just racially incredibly diverse.
Yeah.
So,
um,
they,
you know,
it's not really a race.
And I was,
I think I saw something with,
is this woman wearing a niqab and someone wrote a funny comment about it in the
cup,
the face veil and the,
you know,
full cover the Brca.
And uh,
someone was like,
you know,
that's what you're doing is racist or making fun of this.
And I'm like,
wow,
can you tell me what fucking Reishi is?
Yeah.
You see,
how is that racist?
That's mind blowing.
You don't even know if it's a man or a woman.
This can't see these are knee jerk liberal ideas that are promoted in
universities,
the hyper sensitive,
hyper progressive atmosphere that it literally eliminates objective thinking and
reasoning.
Yeah.
Because you,
you are already automatically expected to behave in a certain way of thinking a
certain way because that is the progressive manifesto.
Like your,
your ideas like you're not supposed to criticize Islamic people.
It is Islamophobia.
The idea that we supposed to be in their land and that is this Islamophobia and
that word is just so fucking thrown about over the last decade or so.
It's toxic.
And I was trying to give the example of myself is that if I went back to Saudi
Arabia or any of the countries where I grew up,
and if they do the stuff that I write,
then,
um,
I have reason to be Islamophobic because by their Islamic laws,
you know,
like,
it's just not something I like thinking about what could happen to me.
Well,
you're an apostate,
an apostate.
You should be beheaded,
right?
Isn't that the idea?
Technically I should be the fuck man.
You should be phobic of those ideas.
I know.
It's a legitimate
fear and it's,
it's not irrational by any means.
Phobia means a fear,
right?
Does it,
does it mean irrational?
Just international?
I think the medical definition is an irrational fear,
like irrational fear.
I think any fear of being beheaded,
you mean not yet super rational.
Exactly.
So that's why that makes it even more of a misnomer.
If somebody writes down,
I want to cut your fucking head off and you don't,
you're a phobic of that person.
Like what?
Well,
of course I went to cut my head off because of a belief.
So you know,
there's that aspect and then there's also the anti Muslim bigotry which is a
separate thing which is real.
Yeah.
And it's based on people's targeting people.
And you know,
I,
I have been on the receiving end of that as well.
I mean that has happened.
I mean people have told me after the Charlie Hebdo toxic and people said,
you know,
you guys scummy should get outta here wherever you heard this.
This is like on twitter or facebook messages.
Like I'll get emails,
real people or eggs.
It sounded pretty real.
You know what I'm saying?
Like was it like a person where you knew you could track their account?
You could read their.
Yeah,
I knew them.
Like I know I know who these people are.
Oh,
you know them.
Many of them are real
life.
No,
not in person.
not in person over here.
Fortunately like I haven't really had that.
The only sort of personal thing I've had is,
you know,
the Tsa at the airport,
the random checks.
Like I always get selected for the random check and things like that.
Look at you.
There you go.
So that happens and then,
uh,
you know,
my passport has,
by like the,
my record of living in all these different Middle Eastern countries and the name
and the skin color,
so that does
put me in the same category.
So I share that experience with a lot of people who do look like me and have the
same name that I do.
But the problem with the word Islam phobia is that I think it's an injustice and
it's actually an insult to the struggles of Muslims who have genuinely been
victim of anti Muslim bigotry to use their pain and their experience and
exploited to stifle criticism of Islam.
Hm.
Yeah,
that's I,
I would say that that makes sense.
You know,
sort of the same way anyone who disagrees with feminist ideology is
automatically some sort of a,
a woman hater misogynists to someone who's just a big hit in some way against
the female gender.
That's just how it is,
man.
People love to silence ideas with a real simple categorization of you.
You know,
you are a racist,
you are a warmonger.
You are a,
you know,
I saw someone who wrote that about Christopher Hitchens,
that he was a sexist and a warmonger and I'm like,
okay.
Did you read any of what he wrote?
Did you listen to any of what he said?
Like that's,
that's kind of hilarious.
Like categorize someone and dismissed them so openly.
Yeah,
with the labels and I think a lot of times you know,
you don't even have definitions for these terms.
When you say Islamophobias,
if you ask someone in a Muslim liberal Muslim in Boston,
you know what Islam is,
they'll give you a very different definition than someone who's an isis or the
Taliban and we don't claim to be Muslim so they have different definitions of
it.
I think feminism is the same way.
You can talk to 10 different feminists in 10 different definitions.
This is a real problem with groups in that sense.
Ideological groups in that sense,
whether it's men's rights advocates are.
I mean men's rights advocates are some of the most fucking hilarious people
online to read their websites and their discussion groups and just a bunch of
angry.
Weird.
That's a recent discovery.
I actually didn't know about these guys until like a couple of years ago.
I didn't know about them until I was accused of being one.
Somebody called me an Mra and I.
What the fuck is that?
Some some angry woman was barking at me on twitter calling me an MRA for.
I forget what it was about.
So I went and looked at it and I was like,
Oh fucking Christ.
I've found the community this.
I tapped into this vein of men to fucking get over
it.
Yeah,
I know.
I just.
And it's what really sucks sometimes is that you know,
when,
when you have a certain agenda associated with just a really radical,
insane group,
then even if they have legitimate viewpoints about something,
if they have like supposedly they have like one or two points that are
legitimate,
you know,
I guess if you're talking about the men's rights,
custody,
child custody and things like that one,
those are the two that would make sense to you.
So that's where it ends.
Yeah.
That's like a rational conversation you can have.
The problem is anytime you start talking about those issues,
you'll automatically get labeled as part of that.
Yeah,
so there's this sort of smearing all painting you with the same brush as
everybody else,
but one of the most hilarious things that I read was that a men's rights
advocates are unnecessary because feminism addresses equality and once women are
treated as completely equal,
then and only then should we address men's rights and I'm like,
that's hilarious.
Like that is just some weird angry girl who no one wants to touch and she just
has a lot of bitterness and this is what they're spouting out.
I've always.
Actually,
I was talking to a friend about this yesterday that I think when when you have
movements and you have like organized movements,
it's something that you want to achieve.
Being in opposition to something just makes a lot more sense and it's more
unifying than standing for something and explained that it was like,
look,
you know,
if you have,
if you have a say the feminist movement,
right?
When,
when you had,
when feminism meant equality,
you know,
economic,
social,
political equality for men and women.
Then you know,
we're all feminists,
you know,
we,
we all had that.
We oppose gender inequality where we're humanists.
I mean said feminist.
It's just identifying very specifically with one gender and that's the issue.
No,
but I'm saying supposing just supposing feminism was defined this,
that as something that's in,
it's a movement that's an or an ideology that's in opposition to gender
inequality or patriarchy or whatever it is,
right?
Then,
um,
it unifies everybody.
But the moment it starts standing for something like,
okay,
you're not a feminist if you're not pro choice or you're not a feminist,
if you believe that males and females are not exactly the same or
psychologically,
or if you don't subscribe to this sort of gender,
sociology theory or whatever it is,
the moment you start excluding people based on that and you start talking about
what feminism stands for rather than what it stands against,
then you start getting fragmentation.
And I kind of feel the same way with the religion and a lot of atheist.
I,
I liked the anti theist position that when you're,
when you're opposed to,
you know,
the idea of religion and faith and believing things without evidence,
doing things for no other reason apart from the fact that it was written in a
book 2000 years ago.
If you're a post to that,
you have a lot of people who will be part of your movement.
But the moment you start saying,
well,
atheism stands for being,
uh,
having this political stance on something where it means that you have to like
what you have to agree with what Glenn Greenwald says,
being a social justice and then you start excuse excluding people so well.
Then you get into atheism.
Plus,
you know,
when atheism pluses,
I,
I do like I had someone explained it to me briefly,
but I never really followed up on it.
It's a hilarious group of social retards that have decided to make a religion
out of atheism.
And so they've connected atheism with a system or a group of social values and
ethics and attached this idea.
It was just a lack of belief in a deity to,
on top of that,
all these things that anyone with any ethics are ordinarily automatically
believes in,
like a lack,
like sexual discrimination,
gender discrimination,
racial discrimination,
all those things that like moral ethical people already disagree with.
They've attached that to atheism and called it atheism plus.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
you know,
against all those other things,
but now now it becomes a group,
like an ideology.
It's essentially in a way like a religion because to ascribe to atheism.
Plus you have to be someone who,
you know,
these people that go to these conferences and like you'll listen to speeches,
he's fucking droning,
boring speech.
They should call atheism plus Dha because anyone who's intelligent already
thinks,
yeah,
they're your course.
If you're a balanced person,
you shouldn't believe in racial discrimination.
Of course you wouldn't support sexual discrimination.
Of course you wouldn't support,
you know,
fill in the blank,
of course you would be pro women's rights.
Of course you'd be pro,
you know,
there's a whole group of desires that they have or I ideological desires that
they have attached to this idea of,
of atheism.
It's a hilarious.
I think that's exactly that,
that,
that was the point I was making at the moment.
Atheism starts standing for something beyond just not believing in a god.
The moment that happens,
you start know there's this fragmentation starts to take place.
Um,
and,
but I,
I just think that it's better like the anti theist position,
just the idea that,
okay,
it's been many,
many years and now this whole religion thing,
like a respect for religion and all the stuff that's being done in the name of
it,
this is kind of enough.
So all of us are rational.
People are going to take a position against this,
you know,
find another,
find something else to guide your actions apart from these,
you know,
sort of archaic social and legal codes.
And if we had that position,
you can have people from all kinds of,
uh,
subscribe to all kinds of belief systems even to come and join your cause.
But the moment you start saying,
well,
if you're an atheist,
then you have to stand for this,
but you have to be pro choice.
There's a lot of pro life atheists that are still atheist,
so you can't.
Well,
that's why they call it atheism
plus in their ideas.
But if you listen to them talk,
it's a lot of these really,
really weak guys who just go looking for social brownie points and then trying
to get women to love them by standing so powerfully and strong in favor of
equality.
It's like there's.
There's a certain aspect of feminism that's sort of in,
in,
in sort of engage themselves with atheism and they've kind of embedded into it.
And these radical feminist ideas have also like become a part of atheism.
Plus it's very strange to listen to what they say and completely intolerant of
other people's ideas and aggressive in attacking and doxing and going after
people who disagree or who they think have,
you know,
in some way or another just stood out against what their ideas are.
That I have seen a lot and it's a aggressive recently thinking that all these
labels,
you know,
when you see what are some of the atheists activists that are out there,
especially now,
there's such a big moment.
There's a lot of really,
really angry people and um,
and for good reason in some ways.
No,
I understand.
I mean look,
real religious ideology,
especially radical radical religious fundamentalism has done horrible damage to
people and there's a lot of people that grew up in that and there they have an
extreme backlash against it.
And so they're angry because of that and know I'm completely.
I'm not saying that they shouldn't be totally with that.
I mean if I
had the life that I on Hirsi Ali did,
you know,
where I grew up and went,
underwent genital mutilation and yet all of these things,
um,
as a woman.
And I would be angry too if I was impressed by that.
I mean,
I,
I have a roof by the way,
you know,
that,
but the blogger in Saudi Arabia,
which one is the,
the,
a blogger that they've jailed and senator even,
they've been like lashing him.
Um,
they lost them 50 times.
Okay.
So I'll tell you,
tell me sir.
So he,
um,
it's actually someone that I know my girlfriend's really good friends with his
wife and his kids and everything,
so we know them personally.
And uh,
he started a website called free Saudi liberals.
So you wanted to start talking about liberalism and sort of just,
you know,
different innovative,
non status quo ideas in Saudi Arabia and he essentially got a jail sentence for
10 years with a thousand lashes.
So they would take them out into the public,
outside of Moscow after Friday.
Prayers and of folly,
Moscon Jetta.
And uh,
they just take a cane and they lashed him 50 times every Friday until the 1000
lashes are complete.
So they did the first set,
think about four or five weeks ago.
And so,
you know,
we all started writing about it.
All of us really became a huge story.
There's a lot of pressure and then the Charlie Hebdo attacks happened and the
Saudi ambassador was in the free speech rally in Paris and in a,
I think that was on a Sunday and they'd actually last riff on Friday
and he was in free speech rally.
So a lot of people wrote.
I wrote,
I wrote a piece for CNN about it.
I'm know just talking about the double standard.
So how many lashes is this received so far?
50.
And it was supposed to continue every week,
but uh,
the,
he had a medical review and the doctors said that he's not fit to be lasting and
next week,
which is fucking bizarre because basically they said that his wounds have healed
enough.
Yeah.
Critical new wounds to create new ones.
So fucking close up before we rip them open again and lashed with what are they
using to beat them with?
They use a cane.
They use a really sharp bamboo cane with like edges to it,
like what they used in Singapore.
What I know about it is,
yeah,
it's a cane like that,
but it's got.
Apparently it's a,
it's got a very sharp edge,
so it does catch a slice.
You Open 50 times,
50 times,
so it's,
I mean,
they don't even have to hit you.
They can just like lightly and it will still cause cuts on your body,
but they're beating the shit out of this guy with this.
I'm just saying there's a,
there's a,
a distribution.
You have to distribute it between,
like the knees all the way up to the upper back.
Oh my God.
So he's scarred for life.
He scarred and I mean he's,
uh,
it was uh,
his,
his wife was just really,
really upset or names and stuff.
And uh,
after the first lashing,
you know,
she,
he was in really bad medical condition.
He wasn't getting any medical help and she just said,
she's like,
you know,
I don't think he's going to survive it and he's,
when you talk to him,
he's just like a very gentle,
very nice,
you know,
thinking kind of guy,
just very sort of introspective and he's like really more of an intellectual
kind of person,
but he's not very physically robust or anything like that.
So it's,
what did he write?
He wrote,
I'm a man.
He just wrote sort of like liberal things.
He started talking about how her religion and politics should be separate.
Just the basis of secularism.
There was one post that I liked that he wrote,
uh,
that was about,
um,
astronomers,
like there were these,
uh,
some Saudi cleric,
religious leader with a lot of influence,
you know,
who was essentially saying that,
I think he said something like traveling to planets as haraam or,
you know,
at the zoo saying something about astronomy.
Her Rom.
Yeah.
Around being sinful.
So,
and I,
if I remember this correctly,
and he essentially wrote this really sarcastic thing about Sherry as
astronomers.
He was like,
oh,
I didn't know these sharia astronomers existed and we should just forget about
what all the scientists are saying and what all the tilex scopes do and we
should just listen to these guys because they have knowledge nobody else has
from centuries ago.
So he would write sort of sarcastic things like that now.
He never openly challenge religion,
you know,
being wrong or anything,
but he was just an advocate for secularism.
So,
um,
and that,
that's really all he did.
I mean,
I,
you know,
people tend to think that like,
well,
what did he really do?
You know,
but I,
I can't,
uh,
I can't say it any other way.
The guy who all he did was,
he just blogged on this thing called free Saudi liberals,
man.
And so Saudi Arabia is another,
like I grew up there,
right?
That was,
that was there for about 12 years.
So I could talk about that forever.
But King Abdullah just died,
right?
And I always tell people this,
that the month of James Foley was beheaded in,
uh,
August 2014,
that same month a,
Saudi Arabia beheaded 19 people.
And it wasn't just for murder,
um,
there were murdered.
They were beheaded for sorcery,
for cannabis smuggling,
you know,
will probably resonate with you a little bit.
You know,
all kinds of crimes that are not really crime.
Both of those resonated.
I'm a sorcerer as well.
I don't like to talk about it,
but I do a lot of witchcraft.
Yeah.
My spare time,
she cats fucking sorcery.
What does that mean?
How do you get beheaded for sorcery?
What is sorcery?
Up Black Magic doing spells on people.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Promising people that you can sort of say hi,
they can't get pregnant.
It's like,
okay,
I can get you pregnant.
God Sorcery,
Huh?
Your head cut off for sorcery in Saudi Arabia.
And that's our allies.
Right?
Happening as we speak.
It's still doing it.
And it'd be headed,
I think 10 people in January.
Oh my God.
And these are public.
These are public beheadings with a sword,
you know the.
So you could watch.
Yeah.
So if I go over there,
I could watch a beheading.
You know,
what they would do if you flew over there and you were a foreigner,
it would be in the middle of a market place or outside a mosque and they would,
uh,
push you up to the front because you're a foreigner.
They want to show you how they rock it.
Yeah.
You'll see.
You'll see kids running towards the scene when the executions about to happen or
is about to happen.
That the video of rife is online when he was lashed and it's online.
It's online,
there's someone actually secretly filmed it,
but no one really sees.
You can see people running towards,
uh,
where the lashing was about take place.
How clearly do you see them getting lashed?
You don't see it very clearly and you know,
so what happened?
A Kid?
No,
no,
he's not.
He's,
he's clothed.
And then he's got his hands in shackles.
He's guys had raised up.
So they're beating him through the clothes.
They're beating them through the clouds and from a distance you can't really
appreciate what it's like because you know,
the beginning of the cane is really,
really sharp.
And so you don't know exactly what happens.
Um,
it's,
you can't see it very clearly,
but the thing that is most striking about that video is the people around it,
there's like hundreds of normal regular Saudi's,
uh,
that are gathered around there cheering afterwards and they all yell Allahu
Akbar when the lashes are complete and there's little kids like little five,
six,
seven year old kids and they're all excitedly running towards the scene and so
on.
So these are things that they see in public.
I mean that not a lot of people here know this.
There's a in Riyadh,
the place where they do the public executions,
you know,
at least when I was there it was called Chop Chop Square.
That's what we used to Wyatt Chop Chop Square.
Was he sort of affectionate term for it?
Yeah,
there's a,
there's a market of which there was chop,
Chop Square.
And.
But if you criticize that you're Islamophobic,
did you know that?
Yeah.
Because then it,
then they'll say,
they'll say,
well,
this has nothing to do with Islam.
And then you'll show them the verses in the Koran that actually say that you can
be head people for all kinds of things and they'll say,
well,
that's mistranslated misinterpret it.
And it was at a different time,
a source context.
Nineteen people in August,
the month of James Foley was beheaded by Isis,
the Saudi government,
or ally,
the one that Obama just recently went to pay respects to the king.
And Fareed Zakaria actually asked him,
asked Obama about.
He's like,
are you going to mention the blogger that they have jailed?
You know,
and then he didn't.
He's like,
well,
you know,
right now I'm just going to pay respects to the king,
you know.
But,
uh,
with human rights abuses,
you know,
with our allies,
it's very tough to have that dialogue.
What kind of fucking allies are that?
It's like having a friend who has a slave.
So like,
I really love the dude.
I don't want to talk to him about his slaves,
but he's got this guy shackled up in his basement and yeah,
guys digging holes for him.
He's a good dude though.
I don't want to talk to him,
bobby,
he's my friend.
We're going to barbecue.
You know,
what they did was King Abdullah is,
he's a little bit,
but
like the pope,
um,
he's a,
he just says something that's really common sense to the rest of us.
Like,
yes,
I think women should be allowed to vote.
Will Start doing that in 2015.
And everybody praises him.
Like he said something amazing.
It's like,
you know,
the pope says,
okay,
maybe condoms are okay.
He gets this sort of disproportionate praise for saying it even though it's a
rational thing that everybody should.
So they're,
they're,
they're getting praised and lauded for pretty much a bringing their people know
forward into the 19th century.
So there was like,
well,
I'm glad you're not in the 17th century anymore.
I'm glad you're in the 19th century.
It's so such a low standard.
So it's like a really low bar for them.
And uh,
and so Abdullah,
I'm working on this story right now.
Just talk to these two women who,
well,
I saw the story where King Abdullah's own daughters.
So he's got like a shitload of wives and whole bunch of kids and you know,
he had this one,
I think it was a Jordanian wife and he had four daughters with her.
It didn't have a son,
so he wasn't happy about that.
And uh,
he's had them under house arrest,
imprisoned for 15 years.
So why?
Because they spoke up about a male guardianship.
There's a law in Saudi Arabia at that says that women are not allowed to do
anything without permission of a male guardian like travel work.
Really?
Yeah.
They can have some things that can't even do with the permit.
They can.
They're not allowed to drive.
Yeah,
I've heard that.
So they can't do that even with permission of a male guardian,
but pretty much anything else,
whether it's a working or traveling or any of that stuff,
that they can't do it without express permission of a male guardian.
So they spoke out about it because their guardian was there.
Dad was a king who they barely even knew.
And uh,
their mother,
right.
She was,
she's also female.
So it really restricted a lot of things that they could do.
So they started talking about gender discrimination,
you know,
shoes,
uh,
the situation of women in Saudi Arabia and they did an interview in 2013 and
it's online,
it's a buy with Russia today with Rt.
Um,
I think that's what it stands for.
RUssia today.
So,
and they,
they were able to get a skype connection and do this interview and they spoke
out and after that nobody really heard from them again.
They didn't do any other interviews.
So I actually
got in touch with I.
So here's where my connection happened is I went to a school called monarchal
riad,
whIch was like an english medium school for foreigners and saudis as well in
riyadh.
And she was in the girl's branch and I knew these two girls who were in the
girl's branch who went to school with her,
who were good friends with one of the daughters,
the youngest one,
her name is Joe Walker.
And when I,
you know,
when they found out about this imprisonment,
they were just shocked.
I mean,
they went to high school with this girl and she was king up the daughter,
so,
uh,
I'm actually working on a piece about that.
I just didn't whole interview with them for an hour is the,
about a week ago and it's just the whole story's crazy because,
uh,
abdullah is being,
you know,
cameron obama,
everybody's been praising him as a reformer and all the things that he's done
for women in Saudi Arabia.
And he had his own fouR daughters are pros have been imprisoned in their being.
They've been starved,
you know,
they've had it,
a lot of their dog died of starvation because they weren't getting enough food
for all these things that have been happening in the,
you know,
the,
the hypocrisy and the double standards.
JuSt amazing.
And we,
westminster abbey and in the uk flew their flags at half mast,
went up,
dilla died.
This is,
this is a guy who sanctioned all those beheadings.
I mean,
they,
he can stop that shit if he wants to have the sorcery beheadings and the lashing
of bloggers and the imprisonment of his own daughters.
He could stop that.
He could have stopped it and he didn't,
he just said that,
well,
will allow women to vote in 2015,
fuck.
But it's like good job will allow women to vote on things that we agree with.
Exactly.
And you don't really get an option to vote on a lot of things.
Like,
do you
want to king?
No,
I don't want to king.
Do you think that people should have their head cut off or sorcery?
Uh,
I would say that that's not progressive.
Yeah,
that's his,
his own,
if that's his call.
So it's a,
it's a different world out there.
I think it's,
and uh,
that's why it's hard.
Like,
you know,
when you,
when you're there and you come here and um,
you know,
and when you hear like the sort of the noam chomsky thing or the glenn greenwald
thing that,
you know,
we need to stop all this llama phobia and yeah,
when you see the apologist and he immediately cuts you off and it affects people
like a rife badawi the blogger and it affects people like that actually harms
them.
I mean the,
the,
the people that we should be getting behind and supporting in those parts of the
world are the dissidents and the reformers.
I mean there,
there,
and there are a lot of them just,
you can't,
you don't hear from them because they can't speak
well because they're terrified.
Like the same way people are so terrified of islam that when this charlie hebdo
thing came out,
no one,
no one on the left,
like actively criticized it or publish those images or you know,
put it on the front pages of their magazines.
It was,
it wasn't something that was done.
It wasn't like something where everyone stood in unity and said,
this is an everyone's terrified.
They're terrified that they're going to be next.
They're going to get their heads cut off,
they're going to get shot.
This one is going to storm their office and gunned them down because they also
published the cartoon and sam harris made a really good point.
Like it was the one chance that journalists had uniformly to stand up against
this type of shit and just everyone publish it.
every fucking magazine,
every newspaper,
everyone across the world publish those images,
but everybody's like,
fuck that.
Self preservation took over.
But did you see that thing on a,
on sky news?
There was this,
there's this woman who was interviewing,
like when they,
when they did the reprint and they put the cover of know,
put them on that,
on the cover again,
you know,
crying and so on.
So,
uh,
she was interviewing somebody about that and then the woman that she was
interviewing started pulling up the paper and showing the cartoon and she
immediately cut away,
say,
I'm sorry,
we can't show that and I'm so sorry to anybody who was offended and so on.
Anybody who was offended at a cartoon,
that's amazing.
You know,
this stuff.
Um,
there's a lot of,
other than my mom gets upset at me some time.
She's like,
you know,
can you do the criticism but don't do the mockery.
and uh,
as I mean I will.
It just means that,
you know,
when you make fun of it,
when you draw cartoons and it's insulting and it's different now I understand
where she's coming from,
but I think mockery is super important.
Like if you think about the interview or the seth rogen movie,
you know,
you have all of these,
uh,
sort of,
journalists and everybody writing all these inquisitive,
you know,
biting critiques of the north korean regime and all that does is that,
because kim jong un wants to be taken seriously and it gives them,
you know,
he's like,
okay,
I'm legitimate.
Everybody's criTicizing me and you know,
they don't like what I do,
but when you make a movie with like dick jokes and you know,
the kind of thing that the interview was,
um,
and you make fun of it.
He goes ape shit
because I didn't go ape shit over the,
the team America movie.
They did actually.
Yeah.
Kim.
John gale was not happy about it and I wasn't happy,
but nothing happened.
It wasn't like,
it wasn't like what happened here and I'm not sure exactly why they didn't.
That was a long,
long time ago and his dad's a little bit more chill.
Probably some possible.
He might be more sensitive.
He's the young one.
Yeah,
maybe.
Yeah.
Maybe feels less legitimate because he just kinda got it from his dad.
He's a little insecure I think probably,
but he's got fat.
Face it.
Lazy fuck can work up.
Yeah,
he's a.
That'S the thing like,
you know when you,
when you have a kInd of mockery cartoon,
like the dick jokes and the cartoons piss these people off a lot more because
they want to be taken seriously.
like they have these like they can't do it through ideas because their ideas are
all bullshit right there.
You know,
women can't drive or you know,
you should be beheaded if you leave the religion or change your mind about what
you believe and so on.
Those are the kinds of things that you're going to get people flocking to you
with,
you know,
through rational discourse.
So know you have to use other means.
Why Is,
why is that part of the world so archaic and their beliefs?
Is it because that's the cradle of civilization?
That's the oldest form of symbol,
what we know today,
like the oldest civilizations that were aware of that we can track.
It waS like 6,000 plus years ago,
which is mesopotamia,
right?
The middle east,
Iraq,
babylon that,
those,
those areas,
that's where we believe civilization sort of began and those same areas have the
most archaic form of religion and social justice that their ideas are so
barbaric in a way or so old.
There's so.
I mean the idea that women have to cover themselves and veils and they have to
these oppressive ideas.
It's the exact opposite of where the world is heading,
especially because of the internet.
There's more and more openness.
The exchange of information.
It's quicker than it's ever been before and it's really hard to like hold on to
like a really stupid idea today.
Stupid,
oppressive idea,
but in that part of the world,
not so much and it's lIke this momentum,
the momentum of the past is so strong.
well,
you know,
one of the reasons for that,
that's where I think our role comes in a little bit or the role of the west.
The though the us is,
um,
you know,
the,
the reason that the saudis are lashing bride for the reason that they're
beheading people for sorcery has nothing to do with us foreign policy or western
imperialism or anything like that,
but the reason they've been able to maintain it,
reason they can actually keep those archaic legal codes in place and not really
have to do anything about it is because
they're very rich.
They have a lot of oil.
They don't really need to progress to making that money.
and uh,
the reason that they have that is because,
you know,
we've all prop them up.
We have supported them and you know,
I mean,
you saw like,
do you Remember when,
uh,
when king abdullah visited Texas,
I think it was in 2005.
And then George Bush was
holding hands with them.
Yeah.
They were walking around holding hands.
He had to kiss each other.
She got bullied.
Yeah.
That's that.
And they,
uh,
so you had that.
And then in a few years later when obama,
his first year of his presidency was a ge 20 summit in london.
And um,
and then there was a controversy where everybody thought he bowed to the saudi
king,
which he sort of did right when you met him,
shook his hand and hE,
um,
so that's kind of,
uh,
that symbolizes where the us saudi relationship is,
but they have to do that.
It's not just,
you know,
we can blame the leaders for being allies,
Saudi Arabia,
but you know,
it's,
it's of the same thing that you see when,
you know,
people driving ground their suv filling up with gas.
And I will say that every time we fill our cars up with gas,
we're all bowing to the saudi king.
Same thing
with fracking.
Now it's kind of changed quite a bit.
You know,
United States produces more gas in anyone.
No.
Yeah,
no.
That should change.
And I think that that's a,
it is a positive thing.
I mean,
whatever the controversies about fracking right now and you have to make
everything safer obviously.
But eventually anything that helps us get off foreign foreign oil because that's
what funds it.
I mean,
yeah.
Well,
this is like abu dhabi and dubai in the areas that were just 50,
60 years ago,
baron mean there was nothing there and now they're thriving.
Huge citieS and the economy is just.
Just blossomed out of oil.
Yeah,
it's oil and then tourism and things like that,
but it's not really innovation.
It's not like they're providing some sort of service or manufacturing and kind
of goods or they've got any,
any even cultural elements that are going around all over the world.
That is,
well,
how does it touch?
How does that change the woRld?
That's the reason for their success.
you said it yourself,
see oil change that and you change things drastically.
They're like they Are the.
The thing that would put an end to all of them is a if they ran out of oil or if
we didn't need their own.
Would that though?
I mean,
what would really is there.
it seems like there's so much momentum on their side.
I mean the.
The culture has been so firmly established.
Their mindset has been so firmly established.
This adherence to radical islamic philosophy and ideology is so firmly
established.
How does one ever change that?
You change it when you have to go,
right,
like when you have to move on with life,
when you can't maintain that.
When you do like if the rest of the world is moving on and you are not able to
stay in that bubble when you need to have international trade relationships,
when you,
when you are dependent on a diplomatic relations with other countries and you
can't just get away wIth the shit that you do all the time,
then that's how countries evolve.
That's how they progress.
They haven't needed to do that yet because they're fine.
They're in their bubble,
they've got a lot of oil money.
Everyone's happy.
Everyone's well fed.
I mean if they're obscene,
lee rich like,
well,
you know,
like trillium.
Oh they're fucking crazy rich.
I was there like the just going into reality.
You can't as a tourist you can go under the.
And this is,
I'm talking about the mid nineties.
I mean,
you know,
when you see those,
those movies with all the futuristic cities and stuff,
it was a.
It really looked like that.
The architecture of the buildings,
the highways,
and just,
uh,
it's beautiful to see this.
It's the people that are walking around her all wearing burkas and
agent close with the most sophisticated modern city.
It's such a weird thing.
Knowledge.
it gets it's contradiction.
It is really strange.
It's like,
and there's one royal family that's running it as a whole bunch of brothers and
it's,
it's kind of like,
uh,
and,
and the,
the people who live there and come stay there for a little while and go away.
All the expatriates.
It's a,
it's a,
it's like they're running a hotel.
It's like a family running a hotel and it's got all its money and sort of
american accounts.
Those accounts,
you know,
wherever.
And uh,
people just check in and check out all the time.
You get paid according to your passport.
I met a dude,
I don't want to say his name,
he's a prince in one of those places who listens to my podcast.
We had a long conversation about amazing.
Now you may be good as a young guy,
you know,
it was weird talking to this young guy who's probably,
we didn't discuss his finances,
but I'm assuming he's insanely wealthy,
but he just wanted it.
He wanted to sit down with me and talk about the ufc.
He's a big fan.
oh yeah.
Absolutely.
At this weird conversation about,
you know,
strategies and tactics in fighters and the trends and where things are moving
and changing.
But you know,
I'm talking to,
you know,
a guy who could one day be the head of one of these gigantic governments.
[inaudible].
I mean,
I guess you'd call it a government.
It's not really monarchy.
Would you call it the monarchy to kinda.
I mean it's a kind of government,
but it was very strange,
very strange to have this conversation,
you know?
Yeah.
It's a really different world.
It's like another planet.
And to be fair,
his was a less suppressive.
We're not talking about like Saudi Arabia beheading people over sorcery.
It's not that,
but
you know,
that part of the world is,
it's,
it is,
it,
it's almost impossible,
I think for a lot of people who are apologists for that part of the world to
rationalize it or to understand that the way you do,
uh,
it's,
you know what,
it's really unbelievable and I understand that now when,
when I was there,
I'm just explaining the way that things happen there.
Two people over here,
it's just so removed and so alien that people either shut it out of their mind
or they don't believe it
because I've seen that a lot.
And,
uh,
you know,
I'll tell you stories of what I'm doing in my book as,
when I talk about these things,
I was trying to bring personal anecdotes into it before I go into the topic in
detail because it helps.
Um,
it helps people to relate to it.
So this is something that happened when I was in fifth grade.
So I went to the american school there,
which is kind of why I talk like this.
And uh,
when I was in fifth grade,
we made snowflakes during the winter.
I got a paper,
fold up a piece of paper and you cut it and make some things and we decorated
them with glue and glitter and our names and so on.
And the teacher put them up on the,
on the door,
right.
Or the bulletin board and I can't remember exactly.
And you know,
you take a lot of pride in that kind of stuff when you're a kid.
I was like 10 or 11 years old and there a ministry of education guy who used to
come in and use to check the school to make sure everything is operating
correctly,
you know,
like you,
you have to say winter holidays,
you can speak about christmas.
You couldn't have read during valentine's and so on.
So they,
uh,
he saw the snowflakes and he started yelling at the teacher and arabic teacher
didn't even know arabic and in front of all the kids and he Just took a pair of
scissors and he cut one of the tips off of each of the snoWflakes.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
so I remember thinking,
I was like,
wow,
it worked really hard on that.
And you know,
he just like amputated one of the tIps of the snowflakes and then we asked the
teacher what happened and we wanted to know.
And um,
that's when I found out about the star of david.
So david has six points,
so anything that has like six points is a apparently band there.
So she told us about the star of david.
She said it's a sign of the jews.
So this was my introduction to the jews.
I didn't really know anything about the jews before,
but I just thought it was like,
wow,
these,
you know,
these must be scary people,
whoever they are,
the guys cutting tips off as catholics fucking snowflakes criticized.
So I went back and uh,
you know,
I asked my dad about it.
My dad was adopted as a professor,
so it was fairly fairly rational guy.
And then he told me about the whole Israel palestinian history,
explained it to me as well as I could understand it.
And then he pulled out a map.
It was one of those,
you know,
inflatable globes,
um,
and you tried to show me Israel on the map and it wasn't there like,
this is,
this map was,
we bought it in the,
in a bookstore in riyadh,
and there's no Israel,
there was no Israel.
It was like a,
it wasn't even like they labeled it something else.
So they made it all palestine.
Like I remember this distinctly.
There was a border,
they'd drawn the border and the rest of it was the same color as the
mediterranean and same color as the car was as a c,
so it was just like a little notch.
Um,
so it was,
I remember we bought the world book encyclopedia,
you know,
around that time,
uh,
that was a big thing.
Encyclopedias are obsolete now.
But,
and they'd taken out the,
uh,
the entrIes on Israel and evolution and everything,
you know,
you pay a lot of money for it and they took it out so they,
they'll do those things.
Now,
what I'm saying is,
uh,
you know,
the,
this was my introduction.
This is what I saw in my.
Fortunately,
my father was rational and you know,
he told me the right story,
but there were a lot of other kids that also went home.
They ask their parents the same questions,
you know,
what is the star of david or the jews and I don't know what kind of responses
they got.
I don't know what they were told.
So it's,
uh,
you,
you live with that in school,
you live with that as a kid who's even if you're a foreigner,
even if you're going to an american school,
you know,
you have these ideas around you and the kids who were in the saudi schools,
which are separate on the way that foreigners are not allowed to go to saudi
schools.
Um,
their textbooks are just insane.
The kind of stuff they have about jews,
about infidels and you know,
everything.
They,
they actually teach this stuff to kids.
You know,
in the uk recently there was a saudi school that was in the uk and they were
using some of these textbooks and there was a big brouhaha about it.
A brouhaha.
No.
Yeah,
they love the term.
Sorry,
that's,
I was wanting to say that I ever fucking say brouhaha
credible,
that they have to cut your snowflake.
Your snowflake was symbolic of these evil wizard.
Jews didn't their sorcery.
Nobody would have made that connection.
But that's what I mean.
It's stuff that's so unimaginable and things that you wouldn't even think of.
I watched a documentary once on the suicide bombers and uh,
there was a school that they were running,
um,
where they had these images in this children's school of these kids that had
blown themselves up in images of them in these holy images of them covered with
their,
their explosive vests.
and they were,
they had a saying on the wall above them that said,
the children of today or tomorrow's holy martyrs.
And there's just like trying to,
trying to wrap your mind around the idea that you are,
you're promoting that you were going to raise these children to be holy martyrs.
Meaning they are going to blow themselves up and kill a bunch of bad people with
them and this is going to be a great thing.
And then their images are going to be displayed at this school and everyone's
going to praise them and it's,
it's impossible.
It didn't make any sense.
It was,
it didn't,
it didn't fit it.
I tried to find a place for it in my head.
I tried to shove it in there somewhere.
I'm like,
this has got to be fake.
You can't be real.
Yeah.
It's,
It's a tough thing that I'm realizing more and more as I live here with every
passing year that people who have been raised here so very difficult for them to
comprehend that mindset because we grew up like,
I grew up in a shia muslim family.
So,
um,
can you explain the difference for folks who don't know?
What is the difference?
There are basically two different schools of thought.
So after,
after,
uh,
the prophet mohammed died,
um,
you had his,
uh,
his best friend,
his name is albuquerque,
right?
And we're just,
what the current isis caliphate is named after.
And uh,
you had his son in law and his cousin and his name is ali.
So I name I'm named after,
you know,
I don't know how that ended up like,
what we're named after,
but anyway,
so what happens is he had these two different lines and there was a,
there was a conflict about,
uh,
you know,
people were,
they couldn't decide who the successor was going to be.
Some people kind of flock to the califit which was elbow bucker and the other
caliphs and others flocked to the moms,
which was a alley.
So it was his successor.
It was just basically you had conflict about who the successor was going to be
in different people took different sites.
That's the long story short.
Well that became Incredibly confusing to americans when the Iraq war went on and
we realized that,
oh,
okay,
there's a war going on now that we've killed saddam hussein between the sunni
and the shia.
It's like,
what,
wait a minute.
The muslims don't like each other.
Like what kind of crazy shit is this
that they've been fighting and it's not just as soon he is and she has as a
whole bunch of other factions.
One of the major ones.
What are the other ones?
Oh,
there's too many names as I can know for talking about all the different
branches off a couple.
So there's aliens lutheran,
so yeah,
there's a sydney's in the,
as their primary within the sheet as you've got two different groups.
There's the [inaudible],
which is the 12 version they believe in 12 and moms.
And then there's another group that split off after the sixth and mom into a
separate,
sort of like descendency.
And those are the,
the,
they're called the smileys in sydney's,
you've got a salafi sydney's,
which is a lot of the,
the ones in Saudi Arabia.
we're very conservative.
You have four major schools of thought within the sneezers,
the uh,
you want the names.
I mean it's like a humbling shafi malarkey and how to fee.
So these are four different schools of thought.
They practice different things.
Like for instance,
the shafi sect does for them,
female genital mutilation is mandatory.
Mandatory mandatory.
So in Indonesia and in a lot of southeast,
southeast asian countries,
Indonesia,
where reza aslan says that women are 100 percent equal to men.
I would say.
Yeah.
When it comes to circumcision rates,
they are more than 80 percent of men and women there are circumcised.
So circumcision for a man that was not nearly as brutal as circumcision for a
female,
it is just cutting off skin.
You're not cutting off the tourists.
There's four different kinds of fgm according to the who,
so that ranges from just nicking the clitoris to all the way to removing the
clitoris and the labia.
So making it as just sort of a scarring ritual.
Yeah.
Nick,
a circle.
It's still pretty fucked up and they're all banned over here.
So it's,
there's different grades to it.
Um,
but in.
So that's one example,
right?
Of the sect.
And then the molecules have a different belief than hunter fees have different
beliefs.
So,
and they'd range and they know there's really liberal ones within each sector is
really conservative ones.
So it's very wide.
Like,
you know,
you have jihadists who will actually go out and they'll carry out these
martyrdom operations.
Then you have,
um,
islamists who agree with political islam,
but not all of them are necessarily going to carry out these operations.
And then you have a moderate muslims and a lot of moderate muslims are extremely
conservative and they do believe in all those like conservative things like,
you know,
being gay is not a good thing.
Women should cover herself,
so a lot of moderates will believe this,
but they're,
they reject the political ideology of islam and then you have a liberal and
progressive moderates and there are different as well.
So it's a very,
you know,
it's a one point 6 billion people,
so it's a very wide,
it's extremely,
extremely diverse.
What is,
which is the more conservative of faction,
the sunni,
sunni or shia,
um,
this conservative elements in both.
Like,
just to give you an example that may be more recognizable to you is,
um,
the iranian theocracy.
If you can keep that closer to like,
we don't want to vary too much from the sound.
You can just.
Oh,
hold it towards you.
It moves around a lot.
Okay.
Cool.
but it's weird.
These things are very directional.
Sorry.
There we go.
Oh,
there
was the iranian theocracy is shia theocracy.
So that's extremely conservative.
Shia islam.
uh,
the saudis are sydney.
It's extremely conservative,
sunni islam,
what do they hate about each other?
That they're willing to go to war,
the bronx successor.
So historicAl difference between shias and sydney's in it.
So it's like baptist going after catholics.
Yeah,
sort of in that way.
And uh,
yeah,
pretty much similar.
They just have different ideas of what the belief should be.
and uh,
there is an element of labeling people who don't agree with you,
non muslims.
So a lot of saudis will say that the has are coffer,
there are apostates because they rejected belief in the caliphs um,
and then,
uh,
that makes them punishable by death and then,
you know,
you have to go out and you have to kill them.
And there's also an ethniC thing there too,
those,
the arabic and persian ethnic rivalry.
So it's extremely complicated.
And that's why bush,
uh,
ended up in such a mess when he went into Iraq because I don't think he,
I mean this is a hard thing tO understand for a lot of people.
And apparently I didn't know from what I read to he,
I don't think he had any idea.
I don't think he knew the difference between shias and cindy's beyond just the
superficial level.
He probably had no idea that that was going to go down and there was going to be
some sort of a brutal civil war.
Try to reclaim power mean no one,
no one in this country had any idea that that was going to happen.
There was going to be a civil war between the two competing factions of islam.
Yeah.
I,
I have a friend.
His,
uh,
his name is festival pathar.
He is a,
he's an iraqi.
He was,
he grew up in Iraq and he started the global secular humanist movement while he
was in Iraq.
So he became a target for a lot of people and the global secular humanist
movement now has I think 300,000 followers on facebook and so on.
So it became a huge and he was also from a shia family and he was targeted by al
qaeda and they managed to kill his brother.
And then after that he went into.
He was running around all over all kinds of different countries until he finally
got refugee status in the us.
And he came here recently and he's full of stories about Iraq and how
complicated it is.
And um,
some of the other people I've talked to,
they say that the read,
the reason that saddam hussein was so effective is because he ruled with an iron
fist and he kept all of these sort of religious rivalries under control and he
presented to anybody he was fair to eat,
like pro secular.
A lot of these dictatorships are so they're secular and uh,
you know,
they just didn't in the moment you took that fist away.
Everything just went nuts.
Yeah.
That's what it seems like from our point of view,
from our confused point of view when all that was going down.
That was a very strange moment where most americans were standing back going,
wait,
wait.
What's going on?
Like they're competing against,
well,
they're fighting with each other,
like in their two rival sections of white.
But no one knew that there were rival factions of islam.
Um,
this guy raise a aslan.
He is a very interesting sort of polarizing figure.
I mean,
some people think that he is a,
like an interesting historian,
a voice of reason and other people think he's completely disingenuous and not
just like incorrect about certain things,
but that he's just,
he's,
he's full of shit.
Yeah.
That's sort of sam harris's take on him is that he's just,
he's just dishonest.
I,
I agree with sam harris and I think he's very dishonest.
What is his objective?
Like what is he trying to do?
Because my friend duncan is enamored by my friend duncan read his book on jesus
and he's just.
He said it's an absolutely fascinating book and just really thinks the guy's
very interesting.
But then I talked to sam about him and sam said that he had some really
dishonest dealings with them.
Some conversations with them where,
yeah,
he's,
I'm like,
I've only read the stuff he's had.
I've had some exchanges with them on twitter and so on.
And uh,
he,
he's sort of like a very classic apologist and um,
and he's muslim.
He's muslim.
So I,
I don't know about his belief.
I'm not sure whether he really is a practicing or believing muSlim or not,
but he is.
He's definitely an apologist and he's one of these guys who whenever,
whenever anything terrible happens,
it's like,
well,
we got to look for the root cause islam is not the root cause.
And at one point he sAid that I'm like his,
he's one of those guys who responds with everything by,
with accusations of bigotry and islamophobia.
Like he'll just cAll you a bigot and he knows,
especially that,
you know,
people here,
especially liberal white westerners,
that's the last thing they want to be called.
It's just a great way to shut down the conversation.
Then people know this.
People in the muslim world generally they know this.
They know they can completely shut you up if you just accused.
They just accused you of racism.
And so there's,
there's so much guilt involved with that,
especially white people.
We're so guilty.
Yeah.
And the dwight sort of western like,
you know,
they mean well,
but they have the sense that they're like,
okay,
we don't want to be called racist.
I want to be called bigots.
Um,
so,
and,
and I think he kind of,
he uses that a lot and one of the things that he said for instances that he
actually wrote these books,
the koran the scriptures,
they don't mean anything in and of themselves.
These words have no meaning.
It is the people like a misogynist,
violent person will bring their meeting out and they'll see in it what they
want,
like as if the book is full of rorschach tests,
just like an ink blots,
right?
You can interpret and these words don't mean anything.
And,
and I was just thinking about the implication,
and I wrote this for the richard dawkins website is a,
you know,
if he's saying that like these people,
they didn't get their ideas from the book,
the book has nothing to do with it.
Then he's saying that all of the people in the muslim world are
disproportionately inherently violent and misogynistic,
right?
Because like the words don't have any meaning.
Then they've chosen to behave this way.
It's got to be something in their dna and they're rationalizing it with those
words that don't mean anything.
And that's bigoted.
You're essentially,
that's actually even more bigoted because you're saying that these people are
inherently like that.
It's in their dna.
That's the way the people are.
It's not that had been led by some ancient misled rather buy some ancient
ideology and you can't fix it.
Right?
It's like because they're just like that.
So to me that actually sounds,
that's a much worse position to have.
It's a much more bigoted position to have and to neglect obvious causes.
I'm like,
you know,
when we talk about root causes,
anytime someone says a allahu akbar there do something or they say,
jesus made me do.
It was kind of ignored that and like,
okay,
let's ignore that.
Let's look beyond every time.
But when you're looking beyond something,
you're never going to see what's in front of you.
Right?
So if I'm,
if I tell you I did something horrific act because it was,
my political beliefs are because I played a certain video game or I liked a
certain band or a.
It was,
I was pissed off about us foreign policy.
You'll take that at face value.
Everyone was like moments.
Anybody says us foreign policy,
you know,
reza,
aslan,
glenn greenwald,
and I'll be like,
okay.
They said what the cause was,
we should believe them,
but way more than us foreign policy.
They're telling you why they're doing things.
They're doing it for god.
They're doing it for the afterlife.
And when we listened to that,
we don't take that at face value.
We're like,
no,
that's impossible.
It has to be something beyond it.
Um,
it's the only thing that we don't believe that,
you know,
religion and religious belief can actually do these things.
They can actually trigger people to act on them.
How do you,
that's almost impossible to fix it.
It's,
it's a tough thing to fix.
And I,
um,
there's this one after that,
uh,
do you know about the attack on the school in Pakistan where they killed 100
people in 132 kids and they just went in,
there were like seven suicide bombers.
It just went in and they just took out all those kids under the age 12 to 14.
So that shook up the world.
And um,
after that I was talking online to this taliban sympathizer,
I don't know if he was a member of the band,
but he was definitely a sympathizer and you know,
he,
he told me something that just completely like,
it was actually really chilling.
And he said,
he's like,
you know,
I don't,
it's not that I believe in an afterlife.
I know there's an afterlife is like we don't think of death as an end.
You know,
death is like,
this is just a human concept.
Something.
People who need to believe in materialism,
belief,
we know that death is not an end.
And then he pointed out the word,
which is the language from Pakistan for death,
which is integral.
And then the goal actually means transition.
It doesn't mean,
and it doesn't mean death as we know it.
so you said even the word for death and the column means transition means you're
moving onto another world.
And then he went into more detail.
He's like,
uh,
these kids,
like,
you know,
if kids have had the chance to sin,
there's a higher chance of them going to hell.
But if they're young and innocent,
then they're immediately going to go to heaven.
So we don't think of or we don't think that we're killing these kids and we're
ending their lives.
We think that we're actually sending them to a place where they're going to be
protected from their evil infidel parents.
Oh fuck.
and they're not able to sense.
And then he,
uh,
he said that,
if I'm trying to remember all of it because there was some really important
elements of,
you know,
what he said,
that gives us insight into how they think.
Yeah.
And then he said,
the reason that we blow ourselves up,
it was like,
you know,
we were killing ourselves.
Death was such a bad thing.
We wouldn't do it ourselves,
but we know where we're going and we know where we're taking the kids as well.
So we just don't think of it in the way that you do.
And most muslims,
and he was talking about all the muslims condemning it and he's like most
muslims,
their faith is in this pure.
If they really believed that there was a heaven there were doing the right
thing,
they're going to get there.
They wouldn't be mourning this.
There will be celebrating it.
He's like,
but they are a poor faith and you know,
we're of the right faith.
And I say,
you know,
when you.
So that's the mindset that you're going up against.
How do you fight it?
You fight it like that scene from aliens where he says you gotta pull out new
kit from orbit.
So ever see that scene where it's still tax different from what you were saying
about the drones.
Yeah.
It seems like we need a nuke the entire world.
Start fresh with new monkeys now.
People are just so fucked.
The fact that a human being in 2015 can literally operate and think that way.
No,
it was,
uh,
it was absolutely amazing.
But it's important to.
I think I was watching this movie and I know was it a tv show and someone said
something,
um,
where they said that moment you demonize your enemy or the moment you call your
enemy the devil,
you're not going to be able to understand them.
You know,
the moment you've decided that there are the other,
and this is just pure evil,
you'll never understand their motivation for why they do what they do.
Um,
anything.
I think it's important.
Like that was a very eye opening conversation for me.
I'm sure you know what I want.
Please go.
Go on.
No,
no.
I was just saying I've,
I've heard that before.
People have told me that since I was a kid,
I was raised religiously.
Um,
you know,
that it's not permanent.
You know,
life is just temporary and it's the afterlife.
but I don't think anybody really like truly truly believes that that's it.
And that's why this life is useless.
People still get upset when their loved ones die and they still fear death.
They don't want to die already.
If they really,
really thought that there were going to some place,
great afterwards.
So it wouldn't be that much of a fear of any of us.
I mean,
imagine like if you,
if he thought,
okay,
my death is a fucking ticket to eternal bliss,
then it's not something that would scare you if you really,
really knew that these people really know that and they're all too willing to
kill themselves and kill others.
The charlie hebdo thing confused the shit out of me.
Not that people were willing to kill people over the.
I kind of already had that idea in my head,
but the reaction by a lot of left wing progressive people in the United States
condemning the racism of those cartoons.
I was like,
what the fuck are you even talking about?
You're talking about a massacre and horrific murderous massacre and you've chose
to condemn the quote unquote racism of these cartoons,
which,
you know,
it's like killing the people that write mad magazine.
I mean it's not much different,
you know,
mad magazine or you know,
name any sort of controversial south park going after the guys from south park
killing south park.
Yeah.
It's killing matt stone and trey parker.
I mean,
it's not much different.
Yeah.
They know.
What is that,
that apologist thinking,
that weird sort of thinking that's embodied by a lot of those really progressive
left wing,
like,
like really radical left wing people.
Like what is that?
There's a sensitivity to hurting people and hurting their feelings
over murder.
Yeah.
Over murder.
I think that they think they'll always say that I don't,
I'm not defending the murders.
That was horrific.
I condemn it,
but then there's always a button and then there's this whole sort of
Justification for it.
This is a sensitive thing for me because I,
I'm like a,
I'm a free speech absolutist.
Like I just,
uh,
when I grew up,
there's a lot of things I can say,
you know,
I have a friend who is being,
was in jail for 10 years and he's being,
he's been sentenced to lashing for doing exactly what I do here,
you know?
So when I look at him and I both grew up in Saudi Arabia,
we're both writers.
We're both pro secularism.
But when I,
when I say something I can say it and there's no like,
it's fine.
And when he does it,
he gets slashed and tortured,
so free speech is a big thing for me.
So coming here,
like I,
I just don't think when it comes to the cartoons or the movie,
the interview,
people were saying,
well,
it's a shitty movie anyway.
I didn't think that.
I thought it was hilarious.
But the,
you know,
when they start talking about the content of what is being criticized or attack,
I just think it's completely irrelevant in the context of what's happening.
Like it doesn't mAtter what was in the charlie hebdo
doing that because they're terrified of,
of retribution and they're so terrified that they're willing to side with the,
the murderous religious fundamentalists because they're almost Worried that
they're going to get attack themselves.
they're like,
well,
you know,
I mean those cartoons were kind of a really racist.
And they mean.
I'm not saying that the,
that the murders were cool,
but I'm sAying like,
hey,
why are you promoting like horrible racist cartoons?
I mean,
let's look at that.
Well,
that's where the islamophobia phobia comes in.
yeah.
They have a very certain way of talking.
Have you ever noticed these people that are super progressive and super liberal
and they have this weird of certain words and I mean,
I'm not saying that it's cool to mUrder all those people,
but liKe let's look at why were they so upset?
Yeah,
it's,
you know,
it is what it is.
We live in an easy culture.
People are more upset about.
It's not,
there's this value,
the value of freedom of speech.
Okay.
Which I think is extremely important taken for granted.
Very much so by americans.
And so yeah,
that's something that I ended festival there.
Guy from Iraq I told you about.
He says the same thing.
You know,
we,
when he came here,
he was like,
in a lot of people are sort of apologists about it because there's a freedom of
speech and then there is this sort of political correctness and not to offend
anybody.
And um,
people will say,
one thing I've been hearing a lot is a freedom of speech.
Doesn't mean the freedom to offend.
and I'm thinking,
I'm thinking,
well,
that's exactly what it means.
Yeah.
There's no point of freedom of speech and it means you have the freedom to talk
about being offended by that freedom of speech that other person expressed.
Yeah.
Everybody said that.
The fact that you can have this conversation about what freedom of speech means
is that's what freedom of speech is and if the whole reason it's protected so
strongly is because of the.
It means the right that all of us have to offend other people.
Right.
Which was why I have a huge issue.
When people say something that other people deemed to be offensive,
they automatically go after their employers and try to get them fired.
Like this isn't just a freedom of.
You're not just speaking about them.
Now you're taking action to try to get them fired.
Which is very different.
I mean this is a very different kind of activism and it's,
it's,
it's.
I mean like what you're doing is like,
it's like there's like there's a negativity attached to it that's very strange.
It's like it's an aggressive negativity,
a rebound from something that they believe is a incorrect weird that we have.
We have the right to have the right to be offended.
They don't have the right not to be offended.
You know that.
That's the idea.
You know,
nobody has a right not to be offended if you don't like something.
You don't have to listen to it.
You can shut it down or counter speech with speech.
Exactly,
exactly.
That's a very good way of putting a counter speech with speech,
kind of freedom with freedom.
If you don't like the way someone expresses himself,
talk about the way they express themselves and what you specifically you find
incorrect about it.
And that's how dialogues gets started.
And you know,
people become illuminaTed by those sort of dialogues.
Even people that have opposing ideas.
You,
you see,
you can see where a person comes from,
even if you don't agree with it,
you could see where a person comes from.
I,
you know,
there's this,
we also talked about hate speech because I think one of the,
one of the biggest problems with France and europe is a,
it,
a lot of european countries is that,
uh,
they have laws against hate speech and the use of laws against hate crimes.
Hate speech is protected as part of free speech.
And I think that's right.
I number remember the westboro baptist church really where the supreme court
voted eight to allow them to pick a few notes.
And as you know,
as much as you,
that idea is important or anything of the westboro baptist church does is
important.
Um,
that is a right and they should be able to do it as long as it's not a crime and
this his speech.
But,
you know,
they have In,
in France,
they've got holocaust denial laws.
They have rules against,
uh,
you know,
attacking,
like the.
Let me put it this way,
the very same things,
same rules that,
uh,
that their hate speech laws were actually used by the government at times to
warren charlie hebdo.
Like,
you know,
what you're doing is you're engaging in hate speech.
So the same hate speech laws that actually protected the killers,
right?
Protected their right to express themselves and to say,
okay,
do everything from subjugate women to um,
you know,
uh,
um,
impinge on gay rights for instance.
I get all of those same things that seemed hate speech laws were used to warn
the charlie hebdo people.
I mean,
they had that,
uh,
that fashion designer,
who was arrested for antisemitic remarks that he made in a bar.
And so,
yeah,
so if you have hate speech laws,
if you have things like that,
then,
um,
that causes a lot of issues.
It doesn't work very well for people who are making the cartoons like charlie
hebdo and actually ends up protecting their attackers and their ideology.
I,
when,
when I look at the apologists,
especially in America,
I often wonder whether or not it's a,
it's a case of people.
It's like very similar to people.
Like almost like winning the lottery and becoming spoiled and not appreciating
the earning of that money or someone who inherited millions of dollars.
And you usually find them all fucked up and drunk and they become drug addicts.
It's like they have.
They're so spoiled.
They're so spoiled by this freedom that they don't appreciate it.
It's almost like you.
We've had so much freedom and it's gone on for so long with no consequences that
until you actually see personally the effects of those consequences of free
speech.
You don't appreciate free speech for what it really truly is.
Like you may disagree with someone,
but if you disagree with their ability to express themselves,
you're part of the problem.
Yeah.
I agree with all of that.
I mean you don't.
You might think those.
I think those cartoons or stupid as fuck.
I wouldn't.
I wouldn't draw them.
I wouldn't waste my time drawing those cartoons.
I think they suck.
It's not my culture.
I don't.
I don't get it.
Maybe if I spoke french and I understood where they were coming from,
I would think it would be funnier.
But to think that there's something wrong with them doing it to the point where
you're bringing that up instead of a mass murder on a magazine,
the shooting the,
the cartoonists and did the thing you want to discuss.
It's like,
well those cartoons are really racist.
Yes.
The merit of content has nothing to do with it.
It shouldn't even be an issue or something.
I don't even know why it was an issue.
And I've,
you know,
there's this idea that it supposing,
we said that the cartoons were hate speech and they were criticizing and
ideology that a lot of people found out of the belief that a lot of people were
very sensitive about or like a historical or public figure who has been dead for
a long time.
And you know,
the people are sensitive about.
So supposing you had that,
you know,
again,
sort of a,
even the competition there,
you know,
pull out the va,
they used to lampoon religions,
all the religions.
It wasn't just own.
So,
you know,
pull out the bible,
pull out the chron,
opened it up to certain things and there's more hate speech.
And those books then there could ever be in the charlie hebdo cartoons,
like there's the,
if you're talking about incitement to violence,
you know,
killing infidels apostates,
go to deuteronomy and if you go to deuteronomy 20,
um,
and you read it reads like an isis rule book,
it says,
you know,
go into the land,
take the sword to all of the men that you can take the women and the children as
slaves.
I mean,
tHat's exactly what it says.
And then in the quran,
47,
three,
it says the exact same thing.
Well why is it then,
what is it about radical islam where they don't just have that written but take
that and use it in the form of practice.
Whereas radical christian fundamentalist,
very rarely go out and kill gays.
So very rarely,
you know.
YeaH.
They did do it for a long time at one point session during.
Yeah.
So they did.
So it was,
it was during that time that they did do it.
And there is a response.
A lot of times when you talk about islam,
when you criticize islam as well,
christianity had its dark ages to,
you know,
several centuries ago,
I'm like,
yeah,
and how would you have reacted when that was happening?
then that's the same way you have to approach what's happening now with this
song because you know they're going through the same thing.
The books are really not that different.
Like the new testament's a little nicer,
like in the new testament that all the torture begins after you die.
It's like the old testament's only during your life occur on.
It's a bit of both.
Uh,
but well,
how did christianity rise above,
how did they get past that into this lesser retarded stage that they're at right
now?
Secularism separating religion and state.
So the good thing about secularism is that it allows freedom of religion is the
only system that allows every religion to really openly the complete religious
freedom for everybody.
But at the same time,
it separates that from politics.
So it allows us to some of coexistence and um,
I kind of,
I always think that there's several steps to enlightenment.
I mean,
for me and lightened mid would be if nobody had any religious beliefs at all,
everybody was just kind of operating rationally.
That would be very nice.
Hasn't happened anywhere yet.
But I would say that,
you know,
you'd have a reformation and after the reformation,
that would get you to secularism where you separate religion and state and then
you move to a point where,
you know,
people can actually have that conversation and they can reject irrational
beliefs entirely.
But the step before reformation nor to have a reformation,
you have to,
uh,
especially in the muslim world,
you have to reject the idea of scriptural than there and see,
you know,
have to stop taking the quran.
Literally not,
not just justifying the stuff that's in there saying,
okay,
you know,
there's this in here.
We don't believe that anymore.
Um,
and stop thinking that it's the literal word of god,
which is a very tough thing to do.
But,
um,
well,
it's what,
what becomes the basis of your ideology then?
And it seems like people want an ideology.
They want to have some sort of a very rigid set of rules and patterns of
behavior that they're expected to follow.
And if those aren't coming from god and they're coming from men,
if they're coming from man,
they're open to dispute.
And that becomes the issue with a lot of people.
So much so that they're willing to accept these ideas that were written down,
that are preposterous if propose today,
like the ancient writings and stories from the bible,
from the old testament,
especially if you try to say today that you found a book and that this book was
written last week by god.
And uh,
he,
he wanted me to read it to you.
And uh,
apparently fuck all these scientists.
There was actually just two people's,
adam and eve.
And that's where people came from.
An eve actually came from adam's riB.
So that bitches super lucky,
she fucked up the whole thing because she talked to the snake and she ate an
apple and the snake told her,
eat the apple.
But everybody,
god said,
don't eat the apple.
she ate the snake.
And so because that we're fucked and they realized they were naked and that
people go,
whoa,
whoa.
Shut the fuck up outta here.
Let's just stop it.
Right?
Let's get outta here,
dummy.
Wow.
Who taught you about life?
Let's see.
That's when you,
when you say all of that stuff and you know.
And,
and,
and when we were talking about mormonism in scientology earlier,
I mean,
this stuff sounds so much more insane than mormonism and scientific.
It's right up there.
Well,
the scientologists tufts pretty fucking insane.
That's,
that is pretty insane.
But the whole thing about the theat tins and the,
you know,
you're fucking from a volcano or some shit.
They dropped your soul cases really.
I mean this is,
this stuff is just as bad.
It's all obviously fiction,
all obviously fiction.
And the more we become illuminated about the actual true nature of matter of
biological life,
the process of adams and the,
the subatomic particles.
And when we get deeper and deeper into the very nature of reality itself,
the more we can explain,
the less religion becomes valid and the more it becomes pretty obvious that
someone in a very distant time where there was no science and there was no,
there was no base of knowledge where it had been accumulated over thousands of
years of people slowly but surely measuring things and figuring things out and
coming up with newer and better ways to measure things that were based on the
discoveries of people before them.
And we're all,
all of us mean the reason why we celebrate guys like isaac newton or darwin is
because we've all piggybacked on their discoveries and learned more in every
scientist and every biologist,
every anthropologists has dug up bones.
WE've added another little piece to this puzzle that's constantly evolving and
growing and changing.
And then something like religion comes along that says,
stop all this fucking learning.
Cut it out.
I mean the very idea of it is anti progress because you're supposed to rely on
some old,
ancient shit.
It's like going back to when galileo was imprisoned or copernicus was chastised
going back to when these people were were,
were thought of as enemies of god because they had these crazy ideas that we
today except as fact measurable fact,
undeniable fact they work
and that it's also the process.
I meAn the,
the what's at the heart of religion,
his infallibility like the idea that,
you know,
this,
this can't change that immutable.
So infallibility,
on the other hand with science,
the heart of a scientific inquiry is falsifiability,
which means,
you know,
just the whole idea that you start with the assumption that,
okay,
this could be wrong.
How do I prove that it's right?
You know,
with faith it's different.
You start with the conclusion you're left with is my conclusion.
I don't need evidence for it and I'm going to work backwards and see what I can
do to strengthen my belief.
You know,
it's,
it's two completely different dynamics.
So
yeah,
I mean,
the idea that the two of them can coincide,
it seems less and less viable as time goes on.
the basics are the one that when you look at the basics,
uh,
the way that they work,
and it also seems like as time goes on,
because of these ideas being less and less compatible,
the opposing factions,
science and religion are more vehemently opposed to each other.
They're more aggressive about their deniaL or the more aggressive about their
non accepting of these fundamentalist ideas that scientists today are more
aggressive about their ideas that atheism is the way to go and that these
religious fundamentalists ideas that are being pushed on people are,
you know,
a form of ideological poison they fuck with the mind because they give the mind
these very rigid patterns that you're expected to adhere,
to,
conform to.
And if you do not,
I mean the idea of like,
if you don't believe or you fall out of faith,
you should.
You're supposed to have your head removed.
I mean that should tell you right there.
what is,
where do you think,
you think with your fucking head while you've been thinking too much.
So we're going to cut your fucking head off.
You don't think you need to abide by this shit that was written down on
parchment back when they thought the world was flat and the sun was 17 miles
away.
That's what you need to abide by because otherwise you're going to fuck up
party.
Yeah.
Does it kind of brings you back to the whole community thing that I think a lot
of people,
they want that identification and they want that sense of identity and group
identity that religion gives them.
They,
they needed so much that that's why they take.
I'm just attacks on their ideology personally cheer when there's reprisal for
these attacks,
these verbal attacks on there.
I mean there's people that cheered when those guys were murdered.
Those people that cheered all in a where I grew up,
people used to celebrate it all the time.
I mean like educated people,
they wouldn't say it to like within our own living room we were sitting there
are,
you know,
educated uncles and aunts who had,
been overseas and they'd studied overseas.
They came back,
you know,
when something like nine slash 11 would happen or you know,
any kind of attack against America would happen.
Even civilians,
you know,
be completely supportive of it,
but you know,
when they'd go out and they talked to their white friends and be like,
you know,
yeah,
this is terrible.
We condemn it.
There are,
there are root causes far do we should understand what their legitimate
grievances are and why they did it.
But that doesn't justify the murder.
But alone in your house they will tell a lot of times.
Yeah.
Fortunately,
not particularly in my house,
but extended family,
family,
friends.
I mean just on a daily basis,
we're surrounded by it.
I mean when the [inaudible] came down,
um,
you know,
a lot of my extended family,
a lot of my friends,
you know,
teachers at school and everything,
they,
they all supported it.
Yeah.
There was a guy who wrote a book,
not even a good book.
Yeah.
He was never,
I've never been able to read it.
Like I liked it and I've read some of his stuff,
but satanic verses just couldn't.
It's just really dense and I can't,
uh,
can't.
It's not interesting.
It just,
yeah,
it takes a lot of focus,
I think to really get through it.
You need to sit down and really,
well you need to be interested in it.
But it's just bizarre because I mean,
it's not even specifically about mohammed,
right?
I meaN the,
the,
the autonomy versus sit down.
It is kind of a,
It is about mohammed's life.
Sort of the satanic verses where I guess the way the qur'an was supposedly
revealed was that mom had got these revelations from above.
And um,
at one point he got these revelations that said that idolatry,
certain elements of idolatry or,
okay,
it was like these three idol gods and,
you know,
okay,
fine,
we can respect that or people that follow them,
but they're okay.
Um,
and then later on he's like,
no,
that was satan talking to me.
It wasn't goD.
So those were the satanic verses.
So they didn't end up being part of the koran and that's where some unrest.
he got the idea.
So it was,
it was based on a,
uh,
on an actual documented piece of sort of islamic history.
And he did,
he changed the name of mama and he had a lot of similar elements was symbolic of
his life,
but
so because he changed the name,
he thought he was going to be okay.
Yeah,
I mean he knew that it was a satire,
like,
you know,
like animal farm,
they use animals to represent like real people.
Right.
Um,
so he did this,
he had fictional characters then,
you know,
the sort of different time settings
and he thought it would be okay because he had fictional characters because he
mentioned mohammed by name.
I,
I don't,
I don't know if he thought it would be okay.
I knew.
I mean I think
he knew that there would be some backlash.
I didn't think at that time.
I'm not sure if he really thought that he would have to go under a heading.
Probably would've never wrote it.
I mean,
what is he okay.
Now is he allowed to just go anywhere now?
Like did they ever release?
I don't have him.
I don't know if he travels with armed security,
I mean I don't,
I don't know him personally,
but
he,
um,
he does tend to do all the talk shows and everything.
He was really under hiding in those first 10 years.
And this is where the spread the risk comes in.
I think there's so many people talking about this stuff now that we're not in
the rusty days anymore.
There's a lot of people who are talking about or writing about it.
It's all online.
Um,
so that process has started.
So in that way,
you know,
a little bit optimistic.
The fact that some honesty can really show pathak joe's shows you see them
everywhere.
He does public speeches,
he does debates,
you know,
I'm wonder what is like if he does like the bill maher show when we're kind of
security they have.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I'm not sure.
I wouldn't want to see it in person.
Yeah,
because you know,
you wouldn't want to be there the day it goes down.
Well,
you know,
ion hirsi ali,
she does travel to the orange.
Yeah.
Does she know that?
That's pretty well known.
So she still does,
Um,
and it,
it's,
it's actually tougher for women who decide to change their mind about islam
because uh,
you know,
lIke with my girlfriend,
she's also like a secular activists,
but whenever anybody wants to send me hate mail or hate messages,
they'll always,
um,
you know,
sort of argue with me,
it'd be like into your bullshit.
Everything you're saying,
it sucks,
you know,
as you're going to go to hell or you know,
you should get your head chopped off,
whatever it is,
you know,
they'll say things like that.
But with her,
it's always a sexual thing.
Like the,
the threats that you know,
she gets are rape threats,
rape threats,
you know,
just all kinds of things that they would do and she'll get hundreds of them.
Like there's a lot.
Hundreds.
Yeah.
No.
What,
what do you do when you get those?
Do you report those to the fbi?
Do you,
do you save them?
Do you document them like,
yeah,
we saved them and we do.
I mean,
the hundreds that actuallY happened in one incident.
It was,
there's a,
there's a politician in Pakistan who she knows personally and who has been sort
of a very vocal in his opposition to the taliban and she just said that she
supports him,
right?
And just because of that and because he is under a lot of threat targets and
then she had some argument,
some,
some of the people who oppose him and uh,
then the rape threats started coming in and so at that point,
you know,
we would report it.
So we will report things like that.
I can't talk too much about what happened,
um,
but most of the time they come from overseas and some kids sitting in villages
and over the laptop or a cell phone and sending frets.
So,
but,
you know,
there's always a chance to have one or two of them are real.
And this is obviously a real issue.
Um,
but it is just generally,
it's a lot worse for women than it is for men because there's this idea,
especially among conservative cultures.
Um,
and uh,
a lot of the muslim culture is that,
uh,
if,
if a man decides not to follow religion,
you know,
that's a separate thing,
but if a woman decides not to follow religion,
she's lost all morality.
So she'll do anything.
she'll drink,
she'll have sex.
You'll crazy bitch.
Absolutely.
Yeah,
exactly.
Dare Sex.
Just trying to be like an american.
Exactly.
Because that's how they measure morality.
Like there is a lot of,
a lot of the people who killed people and they behead people and stuff.
They were really upset.
Like when they talk about morality,
like lapsed western morality,
they talk about chicks and miniskirts drinks,
sex and things like that.
Unbelievable while,
but they,
they don't think of the murder and the martyrdom and all those things are
virtuous.
They actually think that those things are good.
So
backwards.
it's so,
I mean,
the word archaic,
I keep using it,
but that really is the word.
It's,
it's such an ancient version of thinking and this,
it's almost like an operating system that's so outdated.
Like you're trying to fuck with das.
Like you're trying to like,
you know what I mean?
You're trying to like get on twitter,
but you're only using dos.
It's like god damn the operating system of fundamental religion is so fucking
broken.
I know and a lot of times they think that they have the updated software.
We have the most,
we have the most recent relIgion,
like islam came after christianity came to after that we had this great
civilization.
So and in which they did at one point and why are we in such bad shape?
I watched the world,
sorry,
watch the speech once where this guy was talking about,
he was asking questions or the,
the audience was asking questions about a certain aspects of islam and how do
they know whether,
you know,
if one religion says one thing but islam says another.
And his answer was it's very simple because islam is the truth and everybody
starts clapping.
I'm like,
wow,
that's a,
that's hilarious.
It's hilarious that somebody should look into is ah,
like,
you know,
there,
there
is precedent for this.
Like,
you know,
like we were talking about the holy books around here and the holy books are
very similar.
A lot of the stuff is like in the old testament actually mentioned stoning to
death.
The crown doesn't even mention it.
It's in the [inaudible],
which is a separate,
sort of like a lesser god source of guidance and islam.
And so there's many things that are in all of the scriptures that are pretty
important.
But how is it that,
you know,
jews and christians were able to move past it.
I mean,
they had their dark ages too.
They did some really fucked up shit at one point.
Um,
but they moved past that and they're here now.
What is the answer to that?
I think the,
and this is one of the things I'm exploring my book and I think,
uh,
like with,
with,
with jews and with christians,
that they were able to have a genuine reformation where they're able to bond and
come together on a sense of community rather than ideology.
Like,
you know,
if you're,
if you're jewish,
you can be an atheist jew,
you can be an agnostic jew,
you can be a secular jew,
you can be an orthodox jew,
but nobody's ever going to say,
okay,
you're not a junior anymore,
right?
You did this,
you eat bacon or whatever.
Um,
with christians,
again,
we were taLking about the catholic,
sorry,
uh,
the,
a lot of them pro choice,
they'll,
they'll that they'll still end up going to church.
But you can't be an atheist christian.
You technically can't be an atheist christian.
Not even technically if you,
if you tell christians that you're an atheist,
they'll look at you like you just shit on a plate.
Mean they,
they are not interested in hearing that there's a strong faction of
christianity,
fundamentalist faction of christianity that it,
they were incredibly upset at the word atheist or atheist.
It's a very bad.
I mean they actually think of atheists this worse than rapists.
I think I was reading that they had added a data survey on how many or who you
despise.
Most people actually think atheists are worse.
Worsened rapist.
So you have.
But at the same time,
you don't get,
you don't get murdered,
so you don't get murdered.
You don't even get excommunicated from the community as you used condoms.
Like no one's going to say,
okay,
you use birth control,
so you're not a catholic anymore.
But with islam,
it's still,
a lot of muslims are still in that.
you can sit 10 people down.
One of them's gonna say music's ascend,
another one's going to say you got to cover your head,
um,
and you'll have all these different viewpoints and they'll,
there's going to be fragmentation based on that.
But if they are able to come around,
if they,
if they're able to focus instead on,
instead of the ideology focused on the community,
you know,
we were saying that the identity of,
going to church,
you know,
having your own family and friends and that sort of communal atmosphere that a
religious belonging to a religious group gives you.
Which is a benefit
for a lot of people.
That mean that,
that sense of community is so huge for a comfort to people providing people with
this,
uh,
this group that they can rely upon and they feel connected to and joined with.
There's a lot of benefit to them.
The idea that it has to be attached to some archaic belief system to some
ridiculous old shit that was written down when people had a very poor
understanding of reality,
very poor.
Like,
and that's what's really bizarre about the islamic religion is that at one point
in time,
you know,
in the early,
just like the 12 hundreds and before islam was at the forefront of science and
philosophy and writing.
I mean it was one of the islamic world.
The muslim world was one of the more advanced cultures on earth.
And it wasn't really an,
again,
this,
this is where we make that distinction between islam,
the religion and the muslims followed it.
And a lot of this was done by the matassa lights,
which is very sort of a openminded.
I'm very progressive sect of muslims,
you know,
and a lot of those thiNgs happened not because of islam but despite it.
Even baCk then.
Yeah.
Even back then,
it's always been like that.
I mean,
newton was a religious christian because you'd had the time.
It was like a virgin though too.
Wasn't even really weird.
Uh,
yeah,
he was a,
he was a virgin.
He didn't like,
there was no evolution.
Like nobody knew about evolution.
It was pre darwin and everything.
So this is a lot of things he didn't know if he had known,
he may not have been a,
we can't speculate on that,
but I mean he was,
he was a religious christian but we don't identify his achievements as christian
achievements.
We don't identify.
I'm like albert einstein's achievements as somethinG at the stewart and he
wasn't even albert einstein.
It wasn't even reliGious.
So,
um,
but so with this,
the fact that there were muslims in a certain part of the world that we're
engaging in,
you know,
a lot of scientific inquiry and they were really moving forward and there were
being progressive and they're making new discoveries.
Know this is something that is more of a,
it's a more of a testament to science and to free thinking than it is to the
religion itself.
They just seem to be muslims that's similar to the fact that
darwin,
when he was proposing use theories that predominant scientific community was
christian [inaudible] most of the people that he told his ideas to were in
opposition of these ideas initially because it went opposite of their christian
beliefs.
Like,
yeah,
we think of scientists today as being almost universally secular or at least the
ones that we pay attention to and respect.
We think of them as having at the very least an agnostic religious base.
But back then there were predominantly
christian.
Yeah,
a lot of them.
They were in America and everywhere.
And I think what we do is we sometimes Look at it other way around when you
have,
when you had all that scientific progress happening,
um,
in the sort of the golden age of muslims.
Um,
then that was happening again,
like it was happening despite the fact that it was islam.
Now when you have all of these,
uh,
all the terrorism,
all these things happening,
there's a direct relationship between words in the scripture and what they're
doing.
So what we do is now we say,
okay,
just because they're muslims,
they just happened to be muslim.
That's why they're doing it.
But at that time we actually attributed to islam when it's really the other way
around.
Right.
That makes sense.
Like there's a,
there isn't anything in the quran that had been.
The crown says strange things,
just like any other holy scripture in [inaudible] 86,
right?
Verses five to seven,
it says that a man was created from a fluid ejected between the backbone and the
ribs.
So essentially it's saying that semen or sperm was created in the chest.
You know,
this is like a backbone and the ribs,
the backbone and the ribs.
So 86 feeling the belly rent could be looking at this room.
Yeah,
I mean you can broaden it and you can,
you can try to just select where your liver,
the lower lower ribs if you think so.
That could be.
I think it's just the testes man.
It couldn't be,
so that seems like a pretty vague the ribs.
It's like,
yeah,
it's like saying chicago is in the western hemisphere,
but you miss the western hemisphere because this is really a,
you know,
there's absolutely no scientific basis to that whatsoever.
Just flat out wrong.
Um,
but you know,
they,
so it doesn't have any set that the koran doesn't necessarily.
It's not conducive to,
you know,
robust scientific inquiry.
Right.
But it is unfortunately linked,
like,
you know,
the words of the current in the scripture,
it is linked to a lot of the violence that you see a lot of the subjugation of
women that you see.
And that connection is something that should be acknowledged.
That's islamophobic.
How dare you.
There you go.
I'm a racist.
You are,
you're a racist against yourself.
You son of a,
b.
How and racist racist.
Just like gross as well.
Yeah.
I've been athletic.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
He was a silly boy.
Yeah.
That ben affleck thing was pretty weird.
Huh?
[inaudible].
I think he was just trying to get brownie points though that on that show.
like the fact that that happened.
It was,
there was such outrage everywhere,
like I've just noticed that when someone says something like that or if there's
a curtain Burned or cartoons drawn,
this is like a lot of outrage,
but it just not the kind of thing you see when people burn people alive or
something.
Then you get hashtags and when boko haram like bulk around killing 2000 people,
kidnapping all those school girls,
you get to hashtags and things.
You don't get the kind of outcry that you get over cartoons.
Yeah.
That will.
That was in africa too and you know,
we have a of this going on over there.
No,
like dark floor.
It's like 500,000 people killed by an arab,
the ga.
We'd militia and we could go on and on and on forever,
right?
Yeah,
we could.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Before I get too depressed,
let's end this.
Yeah.
When will your book be available?
Um,
I'm still working on it right now where I'm in the middle of sort of like
negotiating,
like talking to publishers.
So it's still happening.
It's a,
there's more interest in it than I thought there would be.
So it's a good thing.
So I'm,
uh,
I'm actually,
I'm looking forward to it.
I think the timeline is probably,
I would say about a year that's like my personal goal will let me know when it's
done and it's out.
And let's do this again,
man.
This is great.
It'd be awesome.
Give people your twitter address.
What is your twitter address?
A twitter addresses?
Uh,
ali rizvi.
It's a l I a,
m,
j,
a,
d,
r I,
z e v I and a website they can go to as well.
A website you can just go.
Go ahead.
And I've got a huffington post archives.
So it's just huffington post,
dotcom slash alley hyphen,
a hyphen,
rizvi ray conversation.
man,
I really appreciate it.
There's a lot of fun.
Yeah,
thank you.
I don't want to say fun.
Stimulating,
depressing at times,
but at least it's.
Yes.
Very enlIghtening.
Thank god I have a diagnosis before you get into management.
a diagnosis is not the fun part.
Yeah,
exactly.
Well,
thank you brother.
Appreciate it.
Yeah,
thank you.
It is.
It's a tough situation.